history has been made Donald Trump's mug
shot shattering the internet over 200
million views in the New York Times oh
they're they're mildly perturbed here
because all of the Trump allies are
smiling in their mug shots but that
can't be they quite literally wrote an
article asking why people are smiling
because they're losing their minds we'll
talk about that stuff plus uh just just
in general about Trump one of the one of
the article other articles is popping up
is they're all Furious that Trump listed
his weight as 215. we'll definitely talk
about that and then we got Oliver
Anthony I absolutely love this Oliver
Anthony roasting the GOP for playing his
song during the debate and he's like I
wrote that song about you and I just
love it because I'm not gonna plan to
speak for that guy he speaks for
alorinthe he speaks for himself but I
love the idea that they played that song
for people up there demanding War Oliver
Anthony literally criticizes it you got
money for proxy wars but not for the
people here and I'm like yes and that's
just like General populism so we're
gonna talk about all that but before we
get started my friends
check out
carriejams.substack.com the dirty
realist link is in the description in
the description below Carrie chance a
member of timcast Friday is Our member
shout out is a therapist who is uh well
let me let me give you the full
description I have a better description
Dr Kerry James a therapist writer and
author with a suspect suspect page the
dirty realist where she writes about
shifting culture destroying mental
health and how to fight back she's got a
fiction novel coming out later this year
based on her own struggles and path to
Identity action-packed and catech story
with an overall message that promotes
individualism authenticity and
responsibility we are eternally grateful
for all of you as members so check out
Carrie
k-a-r-i-j-a-n-z.substack.com and uh
every Friday we are going to shout out
one of our members in the Discord you
guys you know submit talk about it and
then we'll uh we'll choose when you guys
shout out because you guys are what make
all this possible I also want to mention
if you go to timcast.com timcast irlx
Miami uh so it is now officially open to
anyone to buy
and uh it's gonna be it's gonna be a big
show we got Patrick Bet David Donald
Trump Jr Matt Gates and it's me and
lucrutkowski we've got 757 tickets
remaining and it just went live
yesterday we expect them to sell out
probably really really quickly and it's
going to be a Big Show sponsored by
Public Square and we're really excited I
can't even begin to express the the uh
honor and privilege that it is to have
these three individuals joining us I
mean Trump Junior Patrick but David an
amazing show Trump Jr of course a
tremendous force in politics with his
dad as well Matt Gates my favorite
member of Congress so I really hope you
guys do come to hang out with us Friday
October 6 2023 17 30 GMT minus 400
eastern daylight time and also become a
member at timcast.com to support the
show we do not have a members only show
just uh tonight but Monday through
Thursday you can hang out as a member
submit questions and even call into talk
to us joining us tonight after you smash
that like button we got fresh and fit
hey what's up man we're back we're back
you're here this morning you're here now
uh who are you guys what do you do
good all right fresh you got it first
well you know me being black I'll go
first uh my name is fresh party freshman
podcast one half of the uh show and uh
I'm a small kid from Barbados came over
here seven years ago started a podcast
with Myron Gaines and today we have a
freshman fit podcast as you know today
Marion Gaines won half of the first fit
podcast uh former special agent Homeland
Security investigations I did that for
approximately 10 years and uh yeah we do
a podcast called fresher fit number one
male self-approval podcast in the world
we talk about getting your money on
point being attractive getting in shape
and not being a loser in the current
Marketplace that is not favorable to men
how often do you talk about battle
agency stuff on your show I have another
Channel called fed reacts where I do uh
True Crime stuff when I cover oh right
on yeah well this is going to be
interesting with your experience you
were already telling us a lot of stuff
before the show started I think it'll be
pretending to Trump and these charges
yeah we'll get into that for sure we got
Brett yo what's going on guys this is
protacific I do pop culture crisis
Monday through Friday 3 P.M Eastern
Standard Time right here on YouTube I am
filling in for Ian here tonight
and I am Kellen excuse me got a frog in
my throat uh I do all the kind of behind
the scenes stuff here do all the
post-production all the clips that you
guys see if you have someone that can't
sit down and get through a two-hour
podcast tell them to go on Tim cast IRL
YouTube right and check out the clips
they're all the stories that we cover
each and every episode it's like 10 15
minutes a lot easier to consume that way
but uh yeah thanks for hanging out with
you guys uh it'll be good let's go let's
jump into the first story oh man I love
this why are trumps accused
co-conspirators smiling in their mug
shots a booking photo normally reflects
gravity bewilderment and even surprise
that's not the case with some of the
former presidents co-defendants look at
Jenna Ellis and David Shaffer in their
mugshots in Georgia I saw this and I
started thinking about it all the
defendants they seem to be having a
pretty good time you know I don't know
about this these are other people you
know but uh I think the answer is
it also uh goes into why they all just
surrendered without question
they've there's a strategy that we don't
know they see something coming they are
extremely confident that this is not
going to go the way the Democrats plan
it to go and that's why they're laughing
about it I don't know exactly what that
is I know that we got uh we have Trump's
mug shot Donald Trump posted his first
tweet in two and a half years on his
first acts formerly Twitter and it's his
mug shot and he's selling merch if you
go to his website and scroll down I
think they have it legendary dude
absolutely look at this yeah Never
Surrender mug mug mug shot
[Laughter]
mug sorry it's kind of surreal because
there's like one of the things that I
love to watch they make these AI videos
of trump in jail singing songs with Joe
Biden and Barack Obama yeah and now I'm
seeing the actual mugshot I think the
mugshots better than the AI pictures of
him that's crazy though hey you smart
though yeah man to the heart
more merch but uh if I was these people
I would have smiled like the Defiance
for being a having a photo that bad
taken of you with like the really bad
lighting inside you know it's like
there's like a flash on the camera while
the room is already overly lit just to
just laugh in their face right it's an
act of defiance so I love how fast they
got this up too
it's like he tweeted this very quickly
after he left the Georgia jail the image
comes up and he's already got t-shirts
for sale to be fair everybody did what
we did over at timcast is we we made the
Revenge poster where it looks like the
Obama hope poster but it's Trump's mug
shot where he's like looking all vicious
and it says Revenge yeah I just want to
say to anybody who sees that graphic
that the one that we made free to use
and distribute we we it's free for
public use we have asserted that I don't
want to own that image I want everyone
to use that image but we did put up a
shirt for sale I just want to make sure
everyone realizes you can take that and
make your own shirt you don't gotta buy
from us some people just don't feel like
it they wanted to buy a shirt I'll take
it but you can take that image and do
whatever you want with it wow nice
it's funny because everyone on Instagram
is now posting that as their profile
picture yeah on Instagram yeah it's
legendary yeah honestly and it's the
first thing that Democrats and
Republicans have agreed on in like years
because everyone loves the photo the
Democrats love it because they hate him
the Republicans in the in the populace
love it because they love him yeah and
they they understand that it's him in an
act of defiance yeah he's going to go up
in the polls after this he's gone gone
up in the polls every single time he got
indicted so but I'm just kidding so a
former president could be accused of
this and actually possibly go to jail
that's crazy bro it is wild this is
America right I mean it is wild I mean
it's been a Witch Hunt I mean from Alvin
Bragg up in New York all the way to Jack
Smith uh down in you know dadding them
down in Florida and then in New York and
then now here in Georgia with this
ridiculous RICO case
um and then the fact that they went
ahead and indicted Rudy Giuliani as well
who is what I would call the father of
the RICO it's it's crazy look at Trump's
prediction uh Trump's moving in the
prediction Market his indictment made
him go up three cents so if you look at
the 30 day you can see that he like dips
down a little bit and then he spikes
back up 50 57 58 61. I don't know about
polls whatever all I can tell you is
that Donald Trump
the prediction Market believes he will
be the Republican Presidential nominee
yeah and they believe it more so that
he's been indicted and a mug shot came
out
this is this is what I'm curious about
what does it say about the state of this
country that both Democrats and
Republicans are utilized are celebrating
this as a fundraising ticket as a
merchandising opportunity you know there
are there are people on the left making
merch of his mug shot saying like you
know criticizing him then there's
conservatives posting the same mug the
mug shot on mugs and shirts saying
Justice Revenge Etc everybody likes the
photo for different reasons yeah my
concern is
what's the next step what's if if if
we're all here at this level
what's love what's the next level Donald
Trump actually goes to jail and then you
get the right fundraising off and being
in jail and the left fundraising of him
being in jail and then what comes after
that what comes after that they're not
stopping it just keeps getting crazier
Secret Service stay with him if he goes
to jail yes they so they have to stay in
jail with him yep so I've done I've done
Secret Service details before
um I protected a president of a foreign
country out in Africa one time and uh
well I'm sorry one of our presidents no
no foreign country because it was the
U.N yeah a foreign president because so
so what ends up happening right so HSI
is under DHS alongside Secret Service so
whenever you have the UN meetings it's
typically in September um at least when
I was on the job but
they don't have the manpower to cover
everybody so they you know they augment
it with getting HSI agents in to help
them out as well so you know they're
pretty thorough with their you know with
their details and stuff like that and as
far as like the president goes I don't
know how they would actually be able to
incarcerate them like everyone that sees
them you have to have a you know a site
survey a week or two prior wow so I
don't know how they would be able to
actually jail them I mean the only way I
could think of them actually putting him
in some type of incarceration is huge
they would maybe have to build another
facility for him maybe they'd have to
put them on house arrests house arrest
for yeah it would have to be house
arrest because it would be a nightmare a
logistical nightmare for the Secret
Service to protect him while he's in
jail so of course he'd have to be
isolated but then all the prison guards
are coming the food that comes into him
they can't put him on house arrest in
Georgia he didn't live there
maybe you could get a residence there I
don't know but I mean what is it like if
Trump is convicted in Georgia they have
to put him in jail he went to the jail
already he wrote about he complained
about he said it was awful if they say
okay fine we get it we'd have to shut
down an entire wing of the prison just
for Trump Secret Service and all of that
stuff so we're gonna put him on house
arrest what do they do make him buy a
house
offer him hey if you buy a house you get
house arrest otherwise you're going to
jail Dan bongino said Trump should just
not pay not post bond and force them to
figure out what the they're gonna do
oh because he's a former secret service
agent yeah yeah he said Federal
supremacy clause they could just shut
down the whole prison what are they
going to do about it
you know what if he didn't post a bond
that would cause a logistical nightmare
for them that would actually wow it's
actually pretty smart I got I got it but
he knows that because he's former Secret
Service so he knows the nightmare it is
to protect the president United States
if it were me wow I'm not Trump and you
can tell me that I'm wrong about this
and Trump's doing the right thing I'm
not saying that I'm right about it I'm
just telling you how I feel if I how old
is Trump 76 77 77 78 78 77 right I think
he's 77. nobody knows nobody knows let
me uh let me let me let me I I because
when he went to court in DC I think for
his age yeah yeah because they said he
would be the same age uh yeah Biden was
when he runs if he wins for the second
term if I was 77 and I was in Trump's
position
dude it's balls to the wall you guys
ever watch Little Miss Sunshine that
movie I think it's that movie you've
seen it Kellen yeah is that the one
where the grandfather is doing heroin
oh I think it's been a while it might be
I could be wrong it could be a different
way I'm thinking of but basically it's
like this really old guy and they find
out that he's doing heroin and they're
like what is wrong with you he's like
I'm 80 years old
if I was 77 I'd be like lock me up I
don't care I'm gonna lay down and then
you get to deal with all of the world's
problems yeah I get it Trump's I'm not
Trump Trump's not me but I I I'm 37 I'm
at the point where I just be like let me
sleep like you if I don't post a bond
you're telling me I get a few months off
I'm just gonna lay down and go to bed
whatever dude that's not weird that way
they're right he's not wired yeah and
he's got a campaign yeah but that would
be a logistical nightmare for them in
Atlanta yeah but I think it helps them
in the long run a lot of people said
it's hard to campaign but think about
the chaos the Democrats would cause if
they actually remanded him yeah I'd let
him I'd say this they come in fonte
we're gonna negotiate your terms of
surrender and I'll be like I refuse to
post any bond at all
I was at the outright and they would
have been like then we're gonna arrange
it do it have fun and then what they'd
say no bail and then I would come out
afterwards and be like if they thought
the charges were real why didn't they
post why didn't they uh require bail you
know what they would fold they'll just
release him on his personal recognizance
and that's what they would do but that's
what I'm saying
if if in the negotiations Trump said
I will not post bond period if you
impose it
they would have said okay then
recognizance right yeah no bail and then
okay deal then I would have walked out
of the prison out of the jail and just
said if these charges were serious
wouldn't they have tried to require bail
or remend they didn't even do it they
told me I'm free to go because they're
unserious people yeah so either way you
get the winning PR move out of it yes
that's like a circus man that's awesome
but in this Trump just said I'll pay
whatever and so all that really happens
now is they get their Narrative of trump
as a criminal out on bond yeah I think
they for him he's like I got a campaign
I got a campaign I gotta get back out
there and let the people know bro
sometimes you've you've got to be the
one being you have to be more aggressive
to put the pressure
on the on on the other player right you
know what I know people don't care for
the poker analogies but we were just
playing earlier yeah and we were given
you know we're teaching you guys the
basics of it but you can have the losing
hand but if you're more aggressive your
opponent s so you might be thinking
Trump could be thinking if they arrest
me I'm in trouble because I'm not gonna
be able to campaign and I think I'll
lose
try a bluff Trump then says arrest me I
dare you how scared are you and they're
gonna say no no we won't do it even
though it may actually screw Trump over
they might be too scared they might just
say okay you're free to go and then
Trump gets the pr play out of it so
you're saying Go full Breaking Bad
Walter White just go with it wrong with
it and just head for the hill I'm just
saying if I was 77. if I was 77 I would
just be like there is nothing you can
say or do I am old I'm gonna die anyway
guys he can't do that he has to he has
to push back into the people he's he's
Petty with the people who who slide him
yeah I do like the idea however of like
him trying to like scrounge a phone in
prison to send out tweets
every every update is from like a from
like a black market found that he has to
get from an inmate yeah like that have
been hilarious but no I mean these are
absolutely um you know no pun intended
trumped up charges on him right and I
think this is a political play from uh
funny Willis or Fannie Willis whatever
they want to call her
um I mean she did this with the YSL case
she wants to do a big press release I
mean they died in him at night she's
been trying to push for this think for a
while and you know are all the charges
gonna stick probably not but it sounds
sexy to say oh we got a RICO case I mean
let me go ahead let me ask you about
this we'll uh
you've actually you mentioned before
you've charged people under Espionage
you've got experience in law enforcement
yes what do you think about so there's a
bunch of different charges and there's
New York there's there's Florida Federal
Jersey I can run through them real quick
yeah tell me what you said so so first
you gotta died out of New York for you
know the falsifying business record
stuff right which that typically is a BS
misdemeanor but they're trying to get
him on the felony version of it which
whatever Alvin Bragg has a hard on
against Trump I think you campaign if
I'm not mistaken is D.A saying I'm gonna
go after Trump right then you got the
classified documents case out of
Mar-A-Lago which you know the FBI you
guys know they did the search warrant at
the place Etc he didn't return some
records They searched the place found a
bunch of documents and they went ahead
and charged them with that right and
then now you got the DC stuff with the
January 6 which they're saying that he
used his political power to try to stop
the election and you know
Etc and then Georgia pretty much hit him
with the same exact situation but uh
with Georgia statutes and they did it
under the racketeering Act of Georgia
right it's a state case so he has two
State cases one in New York one in
Georgia and then two Federal ones one
out of the southern district of Florida
um and then another one out of um uh the
the um the District of Columbia out of
DC so that's the overall cases but sorry
you got something Tim no yeah but that's
that's the general overall the general
question of what what do you think about
the charges in your experience okay you
said they were trumped up yeah like the
Georgia ones I think are uh what
concerns me
um is the uh the classified documents
case and and the reason why because I
actually did a case
on this uh I think it's 18 USC 793 e
someone could check that if they won on
the on the law right say it one more
time 18 USC 793 E I believe is a statute
um which is gathering transmitting or
losing defense information bam there you
go so that's what they're getting Trump
that's what they're going after them for
right and that's one of the statutes and
uh that's if those are the same charges
that Robert Hanson they famously went
after him for the corrupt FBI agent that
sold secrets to the Russians back uh you
know about 20 years ago now he actually
just died in prison a couple months ago
but my thing is with the Espionage Act
it's fairly clear-cut hey this is
National Defense information and or it's
classified you have it you're not
supposed to have it uh and the thing
that worries me is that the prosecution
have him on recording saying you know
when he was I think he was he was doing
an interview over a book or something
like that but they have them on on they
have it in the discovery hey you know I
you know when I was President I could
have Declassified this this is you know
secret stuff blah blah it doesn't
improve the documents that that doesn't
that is not evidence he had classified
documents well they have the witness
saying that they saw the documents they
know what the documents are so what has
actually said that he I didn't know that
I know that they they claim that he they
had the um superseding indictment that
got him on the Iran documents and they
said that he had
classify documents yeah but I don't I
don't think the audio proves that the
audio who knows what he was talking
about well what the artist proves the
witnesses what the audio proves is is
this because one of his biggest defenses
was and I just want to put this out
there I like Trump I'm going to vote for
Trump I'm putting that out there um you
can say that I'm biased towards Trump
but I have to acknowledge that like with
these statutes Etc that this is not good
that he had because it's pretty
clear-cut and the thing is that he said
oh well I could have Declassified them
that's the my authority is the president
he's correct but he's admitting on the
the record that he did not declassify
them and he's acknowledging that their
National Defense and or classified
information to a degree so and here's
the other thing the two with National
Defense information ndi it doesn't
necessarily have to be classified to be
constituted as ndi it can be anything
that's military and you're not supposed
to have that right or certain people
aren't supposed to have access to that
so that's what concerns me because they
they found it there at Mar-A-Lago and
here's the other thing too they're going
to argue oh well we gave you the
opportunity to give some of the
documents back which he actually did he
did give some of the documents back and
then charge them for those documents but
the problem is that he lied to his
lawyers right and he said oh yeah no we
gave all the documents back Etc and then
his assistant the guy that they indicted
um while to Noah is how it's pronounced
if I'm not mistaken he him and another
guy moved the boxes around right and
then Trump's lawyers certified that they
gave everything over to the FBI then
here's what really scares me I read
through the indictment and in the in the
indictment it says that they have
lawyers notes well that's not good
because we know that lawyers right all
the correspondents with their defendants
is considered privilege law enforcement
not supposed to have that so for example
when I was doing interviews if a guy I
was interviewing said I want a lawyer
and the lawyer shows up and they talk I
have to leave the room and anything I
hear can't be used is privileged 100 he
could say I did it I can't use that
right so the fact that the FBI put
privileged information in the indictment
tells me that those lawyers flipped so
those lawyers are not cooperating with
the beer doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if they flip uh if no they're
going to testify against Trump is my
point I don't think they'll be allowed
to no absolutely will and I'll tell you
why I'll tell you why the reason why is
because the FBI probably told him oh you
guys came here certified this document
said you gave us all the boxes right
and there now it looks like they lie to
them and they're complicit in the crime
your lawyer cannot be compelled to
testify against you I'm pretty sure they
cannot do that I'm not saying they won't
because a lot of things they can't do
they're doing anyway they're currently
charging lawyers but I'll make I'll make
two counterpoints go ahead please the
first is
I'm not a lawyer man I could be totally
wrong I just Google search can your lord
testify against you and the first thing
that pops up is your attorney cannot be
compelled to testify against you or
disclose what you said during your
conversations so if they were to give
privileged Communications it doesn't
matter they did it's in the indictment
right and so that's gonna that's gonna
be a supreme court challenge that
Trump's going to win on the other thing
I'll add is the law you cited not saying
that this in any way shuts down the case
against Trump because this is just
something that you're familiar with I
don't know exactly what they're going to
Trump with but this one says Trump had
to believe it would advantage or a
foreign Nation or injury the United
States I I don't think you can prove
that with what Trump did if Trump sold
information or flew on a trip to Russia
with the information he's indeed he's in
deep trouble he's got boxes in his house
you're going to claim that Trump thought
that would injure the United States he's
like there's a news report about it in
Politico the the documents he's talking
about and he wasn't providing any
information or advantage to a foreign
Nation well but again if they're getting
Trump on a different charge this one
just specifically says uh
sections of it there's different
subsections but but they all say
something to the effect of
aforementioned right so I'm there there
are uh yeah there's a million
subsections in that law it's written
very broadly for a reason so but what
I'm saying is that that's the general
statute that they hit him with right
it's 18 USC 793. there's different
sections section e that you mentioned
says in which the information the
professor possessor has has reason to
believe could be used to the injury of
the United States or to the advantage of
a foreign Nation willfully communicates
delivers transmits or causes to be
communicated delivery transmit attempts
to communicate delivery translate oh my
geez these laws
the same and fails to deliver to the
office employee of the United States
entitled to receive it blah blah I I
think a component of this could be wrong
is he he had to have believed that
having those documents would cause harm
to the United States
well that's kind of that's applied by
that's kind of implied by the by the
level of classification of the documents
it's put in there everybody knows when
you have a clearance if certain
documents were to get out right whether
it's secret top secret confidential
whatever it is they say okay this
document if got out it would be would
great cause grave danger United States
or would cause severe danger United
States that you know this when you do
when you get your clearance when you
have certain documents it's put all the
documents are labeled so it's kind of
implied when you have a clearance when
you're dealing with that type of
document that hey if this were to get
out would be an issue so they know it
and again this is this is coming from a
guy that likes Trump but my concern is
Jack Smith would not have indicted him
on this if they were not 100 sure that
they would be able to get them and the
thing that kills it is that his lawyers
certified to the FBI yo we gave
everything back and then they went and
did the search warrant and then they
found the documents there so that puts
the lawyers in a precarious situation
where the FBI can now go to them and say
we're gonna die you guys too because how
do we know that you guys weren't
complicit in it well no we're not
listening we'll cooperate and then they
gave them memorialized notes and it's in
the indictment so my thing is this
whether they decide to testify or not is
one thing but they're absolutely
cooperating I know that they would not
put privileged information like that in
in the Federal indictment if they were
not cooperating they have a bunch of
witnesses
I thought I saw the other day that you
just changed lawyers anyways yeah yeah
we had this conversation the other day
with Eric Hundley and I said that I I
think they're going to
with uh Chase burrow who's being
criminally charged his trial is going to
be October 23rd I said what are the
chances
he takes a deal or gets convicted for
you know Espionage Act Insurrection Rico
blah blah but whatever they're charging
with
and in that trial
he makes statements of fact and provides
some kind of testimony Court heard
evidence that Trump instructed him to do
it the Democrats then file a civil
charge
under the 14th Amendment to remove Trump
from the election because of the insert
because he's an insurrectionist they say
we got a guy who's convicted who told
the courts under oath these things
implicating Donald Trump in an act of
insurrection now we've we we use this
evidence to have him removed from the
ballot he said well but they couldn't do
that because Trump's not been convicted
and I'm like I'm not talking about I'm
being convicted of a crime I'm saying a
civil lawsuit under the 14th of his name
taken off the ballot
his argument was they they can't do that
and my response is just bro there's a
lot of things they can't do they can't
arrest someone's legal counsel and they
did
like Jenna Ellis is the biggest red flag
because she's just like she was just
Trump's lawyer she's not like she she's
not going around knocking on doors
demanding people change votes or
anything like that she's just Trump's
lawyer and they criminally charge her
under Rico and that's why I'm saying the
the Georgia the Georgia stuff I'm not
too concerned with I think if anything
it's gonna it's gonna get watered down
Fanny Willis is a cloud chaser trying to
move up in the political world I get
that but I'm saying they're all going to
do whatever they can legal or not so
everything you're saying about is
lawyers I'm saying well maybe they can't
do that they're gonna and that's why
politically the left does so much better
right because they just ignore the rules
all the time anyway they do the
Republicans are for the most part like
we always say just Democrats going the
speed limit because the Democrats know
that power is gained not by following
the rules but by breaking them and they
don't have a problem with that because
most of the people have been poisoned by
the media anyways like I have friends on
both sides as people on both sides
posting the mug shot and the people who
don't like women are posting it they
can't even really articulate why yeah or
explain why these charges in particular
are so egregious they just know they
don't like them and so you take a
general public that's been poisoned
against someone by the media and you
take politicians and activist DA's who
have no problem wielding political and
legal power against someone even if it's
against the law you know if it doesn't
follow the letter of the law and you get
to a place like this and then somebody
asks how did our country get here well
that's how it got here yeah and like I
said the Georgia stuff I'm not too too
worried about the classified documents
has me concerned right as a trump
supporter so because because I know how
that statue it's very I mean you read it
it's extremely it's broadly written geez
and it's and it's designed to go after
people for Espionage so they're going to
do everything in their power to get you
in every nook and cranny and yeah dude
it's and then the fact that the lawyers
are probably going to cooperate we know
that they're going to try to flip the
guy that tried to destroy the
surveillance footage they're gonna try
to flip his assistant natsua they're
gonna and it is what it is man I mean
the only way I see him beating this is
my my situation my what I think is he
would have to become president and
pardon himself but it's not explicitly
written in the Constitution if a
president can pardon himself it's just
that he can pour it in so for the
federal charges if not for the state
stuff I know me and you had a discussion
on it I don't I didn't know this uh
Georgia is a little bit different can
you tell us I'm pretty sure I mean in
fact but I think George has a panel the
governor has to has to confer with a
panel for apartments okay yeah different
states I think Florida the governor can
just pardon you but Georgia yeah might
be with every State's different what if
another State Board of Pardons and
paroles there you go what if like uh
DeSantis won could he part of him too
uh yes the Santa said he would pardon um
Trump if he became president yeah
important or he would he would entertain
it yeah he would entertain it I will say
something just totally none like totally
irrelevant it was funny that you said
nook and cranny because I thought for a
second I'm like what's a cranny no one
ever says that word unless they say nook
and cranny yeah and so I looked it up
cranny is a very small narrow space Oh
it's kind of obvious what the hell is a
Nook then also a small
it got me thinking about waffles yeah
a commercial is like they're pouring the
maple syrup and they're like covering
everything yeah I mean so I think the
the most the the the the charges I'm
most concerned uh uh concerned with are
the document charges because they're
pretty cut and dry he had them they're
at the house they're classified or
National Defense information
um they gave him a chance they're gonna
argue we gave them months we you know we
had to open up a grand jury
investigation to get these documents we
did a search warrant we look at all of
these ridiculous acts we have to take to
get these documents back that's what
they're going to say the um the January
6th stuff I mean Jacksonville has a hard
on for Trump at this point to be honest
with you but the thing that worries me
as well is that I know how the feds
operate right and just for the audience
to understand
the feds have the luxury of taking the
cases they know that they can win and
the cases that they want most U.S
attorney's offices have a 90 plus
success rate with their cases yeah like
the southern district of New York it's
such these big districts they don't lose
because it's the DA's offices that
typically lose because they take on
disorderly charged disorderly conduct
they take all the dumb charges but the
feds take the big sexy cases so
typically they don't indict
with until I remember when I used to go
and present for grand jury Etc because I
would go in there and present you don't
indict unless you know you're going to
win the trial yeah you you indict ready
to go to trial at that point I remember
going with It's a grand jury with all my
stuff and then we would hand the
discovery over to the defense Council
everything there and they were like oh
man we're gonna need some time to review
this and then sometimes the overwhelming
amount of evidence makes them say we're
just going to plead yeah so then what
happens if Trump is convicted of of
which one that anyone the document one
yeah
we'll start there because that's like
what's what's the what's the what's the
penalty
they're going to label them a spy is
what they're gonna even though that's
ridiculous and ludicrous they're gonna
say oh he was he was convicted under the
same charges that we go after spies with
Robert Hansen
um operation um Shadows which I know
they caught those 10 Russians that were
here spying for like a damn near decade
and then we caught them what did we do
we traded them for you know some other
spies because that's what we do so
they're gonna go ahead and try to label
him as a spy unfortunately which is
ridiculous and it's a lot of these
charges if if I'm not much mistaken like
these are the type of things that they
would always give the benefit of the
doubt to a past president for because in
the political system if you were in the
inside you were given leeway and they
weren't going to go after you and that's
the part that bums me out is because you
see a lot of people who feel like
they're getting this guy and that he's
always been this evil figure not
realizing that this is the he's doing
the same stuff that Obama did the same
stuff that bush did the same stuff that
bush senior did that Clinton did all
these things are not new to the system
it's just that this dude needs to be
taken down because he pushed from
outside the establishment I want to say
this too as well if you if you look
right anyone that applies or anyone
that's watching that has a clearance
that works for the government you guys
know some of the questions ask you have
you ever tried to overthrow the United
States government
um have you ever you know collected
information for foreign government Etc
the two charges they're getting them for
on the federal side are what one is an
Espionage side that they can label them
a spy and the other one is overthrowing
the US government what do both these
charges have they disqualify you from
the government service or they label you
as unfit for government service and
that's what they're trying to do but
if Donald Trump in any way is removed
from this election
bedlam yeah
I just ABS absolute cast it's going to
be chaos yeah they better not remove it
I think for this they shouldn't remove
them if Trump gets removed from even a
single state I think social order in
this in this country ceases to exist
yeah but people need to understand this
I do mention this a lot but you know in
the context
I'm in Egypt during the revolution you
could still go to McDonald's and order a
cheeseburger you could still go and and
buy Goods at the mall you can still buy
a cell phone social order breaking down
in the government collapsing doesn't
change the fact that people are still
living and trading and working in
business or running so by social order
breakdown I just mean
like I said you're gonna get uh the
other day you're going to get people in
small towns
who will just look at a guy with a
federal badge like a guy in a clown
costume like no different a guy with a
clown and a clowns who walks up to you
and says hey don't move and holds a
rubber a rubber nose in front of you
freeze you're like
what is this what does that rubber nose
mean to me get out of your clown hmm
there's gonna be people in small towns
who are going to see a Fed hold a
federal badge and be like you might as
well hold up a clown does that mean
anything to me yeah no I mean it sucks
because you know you go from like let's
let's look at the FBI you go from an
agency that you know was responsible for
putting away people like La Costa Nostra
invest investigating some of the most
egregious crimes against the United
States and you know now their images
tarnished right all the good that
they've done right they've done a lot of
bad too but they don't care because yeah
they're being weaponized right to go
after U.S president they're they're
they're they're they're in on it now I'm
not saying every single FBI agent
because I've actually I've spoken so
this is a thing like a lot of people
like abolish the Intel agencies
I don't completely disagree uh splinto
the CIA scattered to the wind all that
stuff we all know those statements Vivek
wants to abolish the FBI what he really
means is transfer them to various
different agencies they'll never be able
to do that unfortunately and I like
vivec too I've met guys who work in
Intel
and I asked them yo what's going on and
they say everything you see outside is
exactly what's happening inside you ever
wonder why it is that like
man what what example could I think
outside my head people won't speak up
about some issue they'll say oh like
leave me out of it I'm scared the
average person women uh trans trans
women in female sports like obviously if
you ask the average person the polls
show most people do not want this yeah
ask them publicly with a camera in front
of their face and they shut their mouth
and they say nothing yep so that's what
that's what I'm told by some of these
Intel guys they're like a lot of people
here voted for Trump a lot of people
don't like what's going on but they're
scared if they speak up they're gonna
get fired they're gonna get shunned
they're gonna osterize they're gonna get
targeted so they just keep their mouth
shut right yeah I'll tell you from my
experience um when I was on a job a lot
of us were supported Trump trump was
pro-law enforcement you know what I mean
when he was in so the law enforce of
community loved them it's the guys at
the higher up because here's the thing
too I want people to understand
you got a special agent right that guy
is a gs13 right whatever he's doing his
cases he's doing what he's got to do
it's the management the 14s the 15s the
sacks um you know the directors etc
those are the guys that are making the
political moves Etc trying to move on up
the guys on the ground that are doing
the cases a lot of the times man they
just want to do their cases be done go
after the bad guys you know it is what
it is but it's the guy it's the brass
that are doing this crap that where a
lot of times is politically motivated
but yeah a lot of a lot of guys a lot of
um law enforcement guys especially at
the lower levels right they're Pro Trump
they're they're Pro because those guys
are pro law enforcement but here's what
they do
some higher up guy who's political finds
people he can trust to agree with him
and then says they're putting me in
charge of insert Bureau in office
I want you to come work with me
we're gonna do X Y and Z so then you end
up with a particular office where
the guy running it is politically
charged he brought a bunch of his
buddies who are also for political and
now you have this one particular office
where everybody is doing taking part
partisan action
so these agents that are investigating
and going after Trump they like that
they're doing it they're not upset that
they're doing it well it's DC agents so
to so and I'll clarify that too so DC is
super woke we all know this right
um it was actually the the DC office
that ran that investigation and when
they came down they did the search
warrants they did everything and you
know the obviously the Miami Field
office is going to help and everything
else like that but it's the DC office
that's running it so you know it is what
it is man
um
it's just a sad time in America but oh
go ahead you made a very good point
earlier about how other presidents in
the past did the same thing that he
basically did but they got nothing for
it and uh it's scary because you look at
it from a holistic standpoint Trump is
basically advocate for like the opposite
of what's currently in political space
however challenging anything that's
currently like setting Stone here for
the political uh landscape is demonized
and it means that any of the president
tries to I want to say do the opposite
it's gonna be shun too so it's kind of
scary bro and you look at I mean look at
uh there's there's lots of pictures of
bush with Obama they're they're all
friends right it's it's now about Good
Old establishment versus populists and
people who support did you see his
interview with Tucker yeah he said in
there that basically everything started
to roll once he got rid of Comey oh wow
yeah he said in the interview with
Tucker um you know you like basically
they kind of started the Pitchfork
started to come out once he got rid of
Comey and what you how you described
what was going on what whether we're
talking somebody high up in the in the
government who then hires people that he
knows are loyal to him that's why I take
a lot of issue with the idea of during
the swamp they're like get rid of the
heads of this agency get rid of this
agency like all of these people mentored
people who even if they're not
necessarily 100 in line with them as far
as their political views they feel a
sense of loyalty to that person or at
least the the person who's in charge is
politically Savvy enough to hire people
that he knows think the same as him
right because he's training them to if
not succeed him to work under him to
help him achieve whatever he wants to
accomplish right it's not easy it's not
so easy as to just fire a bunch of
people because somebody else is going to
take that job and you run the risk that
that person is going to be every bit as
bad as the guy you fired once once
you're at the what we call the special
agent in charge level which you know
some age some agencies call it Sac or
saic or Etc it starts to get political
and that's the guy that's the head of
the field office right of a of a certain
you know geographic area and they're
overseeing you know sometimes hundreds
of Agents so yeah at that point starts
to become political and they're really
just kind of the the you know the
puppets of the higher ups over out of
the Washington DC office
it says here on uh uscodehouse.gov
shall be fined into this title or
imprisoned not more than 10 years or
both
not more than 10 years what are the
chances he gets convicted and they just
say all right you were found guilty time
served time served I was in the position
of which church specifically the
Espionage oh the Espionage one the
chance of him they just say no fine time
served have a nice day disqualified yeah
they don't need to put them in jail
that's the thing like the fear is that
Trump gets put into jail which causes
Bedlam everyone's like ah screaming but
they could just be like don't worry
we're not going to lock you up we don't
think you're a threat Beyond this
because you're not president and your
penalty is that you can't run for office
anymore I mean isn't that even worse
though then then it looks to the people
that I know that just dislike him and
don't understand how politically
motivated this is that screams
politically motivated to just say yeah
no no they'll have to throw them to make
it seem like there was actually a crime
for them to punish him for if they just
let him go then it absolutely looks like
a banana I think the strategy is this
and I think is I'd said this on the on
the onset when he first got indicted um
and I think his legal team is trying to
do this delay delay delay man he's got
to make it to 2024 win the election
pardon himself from the chart the
federal charges and um hopefully you
know the state of Georgia can we can
figure something out with that but you
know and then the New York stuff I'm not
even worried about that's that's the
best the Georgia stuff is where the cast
ensues because if they do convict him
and he gets sentenced to jail and then
he wins the presidency
what happens when they're not going to
trial though on that for years dude the
state of Georgia is so backed up these
State courses kind of Chase Burrows
going October 23rd for the for the
retail charges that's right October 23rd
of next year no
October 23rd this year impossible they
wanted March of next year for Trump
they're trying to get a conviction
before the election wow they're just
posturing there's absolutely no way let
me double check yeah double check but
there's absolutely no way that they can
go ahead and um try to get a trial with
him in October of uh they could push but
his legal team is going to fight that
and be like Kenny chaseborough called
for a uh speedy trial so they said
October 23rd and they agreed a judge
confirmed yeah they said they wanted
Trump to go in uh March 4th Willis
proposed the trial should start for all
90 defendants on March 4th 2024. wow
yeah Trump's team is going to fight down
and be like we need more time to prepare
go over to Discovery right they're gonna
they're gonna file it they're going to
file extensions there's there's no way I
don't even know why Trump went to
Georgia in the first place
uh forced Joe Biden to send Federal
Marshals to extradite Trump from New
Jersey or Florida Florida is a better
bet because New Jersey would they didn't
extradite Trump in two seconds but if
Trump went to Florida and said whatever
charges may arise out of uh he went to
Florida and said any charges arising and
right next to Georgia by the way are
rising out of Georgia they can send the
legal paper paperwork to my house serve
me proper legal service for which I will
respond but the idea that you can go on
the TV and claim I have to surrender is
not legal service then what would happen
is they'd have to contact what Florida
right Georgia would have to ask law
enforcement in Florida to apprehend an
extradite Donald Trump so I'll tell you
how it would go so um because I've done
this I've seen this happen before so if
you are a fugitive from Justice and
you're out of state and they know that
you're out of state or they can no
longer fulfill that warrant what they're
going to do is they're going to delegate
that warrant to the United States
Marshal Service once the United States
Marshal Service gets the warrant now
they're responsible for going to go get
them so they would probably coordinate
with the Secret Service Hey where's he
at we have to we have to you know we
have to execute the rest this arrest
warrant that we have from the state of
Georgia Georgia and they would bring him
in now knowing Jack Smith and how he is
they would probably also get something
out of Atlanta out of the the I think
it's the Northern District of Georgia or
whatever the federal prosecutor's office
over there in Fulton County they would
probably apply for something called the
ufap warrant which is an unlawful flight
to avoid prosecution warrant and they
would hit him with another Federal
charge because they know that he's
indicted and he's not showing up that's
after legal service
I mean I mean he's been indicted by
grand jury man like all right and so
they the government can't just go on TV
and say uh you know those guys from
fresh and fit they they got 10 days to
go to jail because we said so you'd be
like what send me the legal paperwork
requesting my like they have a true bill
that's all they need so so without legal
notice they can claim your fugitive
without even telling you
they have a true bill of indictment and
they're telling them that he's wanted no
no I'm saying legal service requires
they tell Trump that he's wanted
they said you need to surrender right
right my point is going on TV is not
proper legal service
like if I if I go on TV announce I'm
suing someone
they don't have to do anything and then
if the if I if I never give them the
paperwork they're gonna be like your
honor like going on TV and claiming a
legal thing does not make a legal
service I agree improper serve but I
mean a criminal case I mean
realistically speaking when that
whenever they indict you right they too
they do it surreptitiously they get an
arrest warrant from the clerk and then
they go pick you up so that you don't
know you're gonna being picked up so in
this case they would just say well we
indicted you we have a true we have a
true bill uh here's it here it is so the
marshals would have to come to Florida
and say Trump you are hereby under
arrest for for a warrant in Georgia and
then assuming he doesn't surrender then
they would have to delegate Marshalls
yeah Donald Trump should have gone to
Florida and said deliver me proper
service
I don't know man I I think I think he
did the good thing by surrendering
because if he had done that right then
Georgia would be like okay cool we're
not only are we gonna file a ufat warn
against you so now you're going to get
another Federal charge yep uh now the
marshes are gonna go get you and it's
going to be a problem so and then Rhonda
Santos would have to be like we're gonna
let him come in and just take Trump from
his home it's no big deal and then there
would be chaos in Bedlam make them
follow up with their threats if there's
like these charges against Trump out of
Georgia are psychotic and insane they're
stupid yeah you want to make it you make
an argument about and and all I'm saying
is that Trump should make them follow
the law like the idea that Trump would
take the extra effort to seek them out
when they are accusing him doesn't make
sense to me hmm
if if the police like
no but they have an arrest warrant for
him and so I'm saying go deliver the
warrant go to his house here's your
reward okay take me we're going to
Georgia the idea that Trump contacted
them and was like I I heard on the TV
that you have a war formation to come in
makes no sense to me he should be like
come knock on my door tell me that you
have a warrant or or or in some way
initiate that through a legal process
I'm sure they probably faxed the warrant
to his legal team you know signed by a
judge they they I guarantee you they
gave that to him they faxed it to his
team and let him know and the other
reason too why they announced is that so
he's put on notice he can make because
you gotta remember he's the president
United States a former president United
States they got a coordinate with Secret
Service you got 10 days to surrender Etc
so they have to do all this logistical
stuff but typically you're never
notified that you're being under arrest
because they're gonna come get you and
then they're gonna oh yeah we have
warrant for your arrest I'm saying Trump
should have had that happen he should
have had them just follow the proper
legal protocol for common and arresting
him
oh no but I mean they're going to give
him the common courtesy and then he's
with the Secret Service right I don't
think any of us are served properly by
Donald Trump proactively seeking out his
political persecution unless unless it's
to just fundraise and he knows it's not
going to matter and they wanted to make
a media because meet a spectacle about
it and this is giving and so I I think
the the proper thing is let them serve
their warrant
like go arrest them you like go
physically actually go try to go get
them it's it's not like he's fleeing
he's in his house they knock on his door
like what they do with Roger Stone and
they say Donald Trump you're under
arrest and he goes okay and he gets in
the car and they go to Georgia
that's what they do
Roger Stone wasn't contacted and told to
go show up at their course they went to
his house Trump should have said I'm
here I'm waiting serve me the warrant I
got no issues we will absolutely abide
by the terms it's it's I don't
understand why it's incumbent upon him
to proactively seek out his surrender in
another state when they haven't served
him they've done it they've done it in
all the cases though every time they
indicted trumpet Trump and all of his
allies are surrendering and giving in
and giving them everything they want my
point is what position would this
country be in if Federal Marshals were
forced to go arrest the former president
in his own home and Rhonda said is the
governor governor of Florida agreed to
allow it to happen there's a certain
point where if Trump as the former
president says this stops like like not
posting Bond call there Bluff say are
you really intending a political
persecution and prosecution of a former
president then you will go by the legal
you'll go by the book you will take the
warrant you will get it signed off and
you will come and make the arrest
Trump giving them what they want and
calling them up the phone back I'll come
okay well there's other reasons too well
here's the other reason too I see I see
your perspective but the other reason as
well is that they can go ahead and say
okay well you don't want to show up well
we're going to remand you into custody
yes 100 yeah so and you're saying that
let them recommend into custody and
everything else like that but he wants
to run bro he wants to go around and
campaign and everything else like that
so he's looking at it like all right I'm
gonna cooperate right because they're
already trying to paint him as you
started the January 6th riots even
though he said you know you know protest
peacefully but everyone the left tends
to forget that that he said protest
peacefully but whatever so in his eyes
he's like all right I'm gonna go ahead
go through the motion I'm gonna
surrender I'm gonna abide by the law
then I'm gonna get out and do what I got
to do but I think for him he's looking
at it like if I don't surrender they're
gonna probably remind me in the custody
I won't be able to campaign which would
be a nightmare for them to remand them
into custody I don't think they would
you could call the bluff yeah that's
that that's a possibility on you on that
the big problem that I see especially
with the right in this country is
capitulation every step of the way the
reasonableness the desire to be
reasonable and not engaged you're
playing a game of Monopoly you're
watching the dude you're playing against
pull bills out of the bank and you go
hey man you're cheating and they go no
I'm allowed to do it and you go okay
and then you lose you go man how did I
lose that's what they're doing it's also
as lawyers too that are probably because
I guarantee you Trump is probably like
well you know what no I don't want to
show but his lawyers is on him hey man
you got to show up like let's just get
this done let's do this peacefully Etc
so you can keep campaigning and so what
happens is every day a grain of sand is
added to the Heap yeah and as the a
better analogy is frogs in a pot boiling
as the temperature increases by one
degree every day the frogs isn't
actually not a true soy frogs do notice
but the analogy as it goes if you if you
put frogs in a Boiling Pot they jump out
if you put them in water and slowly turn
the temperature up they just boil to
death yeah because they don't realize
temperature is changing it's actually
not true if the temperature gets too hot
the frogs will just literally jump out
you know
stories are more fun but that's what I'm
saying like no it's I mean
there's got to be some degree of Donald
Trump
at the very least providing the legal
the legal minimum of some kind of
restraint or resistance in
if you guys have a warrant for my arrest
you have my address and I will gladly I
will gladly without resistance right
just go with you when you come to pick
me up Trump paid how much does it cost
to fly that jet 50 Grand Trump paid 50
000 to go to surrender for them
it's a path of least resistance the
other thing too you got to remember is
that when a warrants put out for someone
and they're a uh there's a felony
warrant out for them Secret Service is
still law enforcement that's right and
and I'd like I'd like to see the Secret
Service cuff Donald Trump and bring him
to a van and that's something the
American people should see that's crazy
they're like this is awkward yeah yeah
they're like yeah because technically
because if you look at any any whether
it's a federal state warrant it says to
any peace officer and or officer of the
United States most warrants Iran like
that to some random some kind of
language like that secret service is
technically sworn law enforcement so
it's like it gets tricky man it gets
very very true leftists are willing to
take to engage in a wide range of
tactics from non-violent Civil
Disobedience which I think is the
I think is the most effective and
reasonable tool for political change
generating awareness being obstructive
but not engaging in like overt acts of
violence and like you know no danger I'm
talking about they will sit down on the
street piss people off it's super
annoying and then they'll get arrested
for it I find it really annoying but I
think that's the right way to go about
things some stress on the system but
nobody gets hurt however the left is
also willing to firebomb buildings yep
pull out guns shoot and kill people
Donald Trump's not even willing to say
please serve the warrant and I will
gladly be arrested he's saying I will
pay 50 000 to get on a plane and go fly
to you so you can arrest me and I'm just
like man and put up a 200 000 Bond yeah
20 grand yeah 20 grand 10 but so but but
I will say to be fair
this is just more of a what I'm really
saying is where is any degree of passive
resistance
and I don't want to impose upon I don't
want to imply I know their legal
strategy better
I think there's probably a reason Trump
went about doing this yeah yeah I think
he's his legal team is telling him to do
this but I think it's a political team
too yeah I think his political team is
saying the amount of money you're going
to make off of this will absolutely be
worth the trip the amount like the
campaign will cover the cost of flying
the plane for you to go you know
probably can't do it that way legally
but like the amount of money that you
make in selling merch the merch drop
he's like he doesn't get to play in the
merch and here's another thing too you
gotta remember like it's very obvious
that there the media is willing to twist
and contort Trump's words to make him
sound like an insurrectionist so it's
like by him not surrendering and not
complying they're gonna say look look we
told you he's an anarchist he doesn't
care about the United States January 6
blah blah blah blah so it's like in his
head he's like okay the legal I'm
running for president I don't want to
put off an idea that I'm an
insurrectionist even though I'm not but
the media the media is against them you
look at MSNBC CNN all these guys they're
all vilifying him and I'm like that's
not true that's not what he said but
they do that right to make him look
crazy so in his head he's like all right
I need to surrender and I and even
though he could you know say oh you guys
come get me they could look at that as
like oh look we told you guys on order
guys out here not obeying yeah exactly
so it's that's not an optic situation it
could look bad too I I agree with that
yeah but I'm not saying he should do
anything illegal I'm saying he should
just say you know like I am ready and
willing to respond to anyone come get me
do your jobs
media would twist it anyway and the
average person who's only in pain and
I'm saying this that Trump refuses to
surrender I'm saying this that I think
that the best route for him for him
surrendering because I'm looking at it
from an optic standpoint like from a law
enforcement standpoint I know how the
judges are I know what they might how
they might look at as as they might
remand them to custody I want him to win
I'm gonna vote for him I don't care I'm
putting it out there but I want him to
be able to run and be able to campaign
and win and beat these isn't it
telling that his uh well co-conspirator
so to speak are smelling in their
mugshots it's kind of like maybe they
know something that we don't know but I
don't know if it's that they know
something that we don't know they know
that it's BS charges yeah they they know
they know like you're really going ahead
and indicting his lawyers in this
situation
yeah you guys are reaching you know and
again the state so at the state level
they're okay with putting ridiculous
charges on people to get immediate media
spectacle because the state doesn't care
if they lose cases the State loses cases
all the time it's a U.S attorney's
office that cares about winning cases
which is why I'm more concerned with the
federal charges that Jack Smith is
bringing against Trump versus these
State charges what does it mean for
America if he's convicted you said uh
Anarchy a little bit not Anarchy Anarchy
is is uh
in in Anarchy in the truest and purest
sense
is just no Authority it doesn't imply
chaos or or violence or anything like
that it could literally be a bunch of
people sitting around sharing a peace
pipe you know what I mean uh conflict
active conflict between factions and
uh uh social disorder social breakdown
so
I do think a component could be civil
war
we are likely in a period of civil
Strife right now
uh I often quote Stephen Marshall wrote
the book and studied this
um this is a period where typically
occurs before Civil Wars where a certain
number of people are killed every year
for political reasons and the U.S
qualifies there's a lot of people don't
realize how many people are killed every
year over some kind of political or
ideological issue yeah if Donald Trump
is convicted or if he's removed from one
state
look we also have it on January 6th
they've got people locked up in DC who
have not been charged with any crime do
you guys know that yes oh yeah I mean
I've talked about the January 6th stuff
as well a lot of those people most of
them were charged with a BS misdemeanor
man and they're incredible a year in
jail because they walked around confused
the bureau went ahead and wasted a bunch
of resources in time normally federal
agencies are not supposed to investigate
misdemeanors but they expended a
ridiculous amount of resources to go
after guys right for misdemeanors if you
read those criminal complaints a lot of
them are misdemeanors what do you think
happens when you got the Capitol Police
setting up Tampa office they got an
office out on the west coast somewhere
and they're hunting down genuine people
from January 6. and and I'm not talking
about people who are violent and
fighting with cops because you Riot you
go to jail
there's one guy who's been locked up two
and a half years without any charges
and he was told if you say Trump made
you do it we'll let you go right now and
he said no really yep wow and that's not
the only case like that there's a photo
that just came out of a guy who is it
yeah me or where's he at DC president I
don't know
let's pull it up uh let's see Bop
inmates for that one I have to ask uh
Matt Brainerd okay yeah all we need is
his name and his uh last name first name
and then his approximate age and we
could pull it up on blp we had a podcast
with somebody that spoke about Myron I
forgot who it was
um January 6. I forgot who it was let's
talk about people being locked up
oh look at this fed's dispute story
behind viral photos allegedly debating
January 6 prisoner abuse so let's see
this was Tom fitton disturbing photos
leaked of January 6 prisoner abuse
tortured five months in isolation in a
closet room with a light on and a bucket
for a toilet
so uh the Gateway pundit adds on to it
claiming it and they're saying that the
uh
the FED said that he had nine prior
convictions terroristic threats he had
an assault conviction that has nothing
to do with January 6. okay so they're
not disputed they're saying he's a
criminal
okay
but the thing is a Litany of oh okay all
right it was a Litany of charges related
to January 6. but he was a bad guy so
the photos are real I guess as for the
other guy who's locked up you have to
ask Matt Brainerd because I'm just you
know to be fair okay I'll I defer to him
okay I think it was Matt Brenner who
talked about talk to us about that we
could look it up if Anton would have his
name the guys who actually focus a lot
more on the January 6th stuff than I do
to be completely honest okay so then
I'll I'll walk it back and just say this
sure I met a woman recently she said
that she's getting probably 16 months
because an hour later after people had
already left
she walked over and they there's no
barricades there's no signs there's
nothing and they walked up to the
building where the doors are open
nothing's good they don't see anybody
they see people walk around they walk in
look around six minutes in total they
walk out and they leave next thing they
know they're called insurrectionists and
they're gonna go to prison wow and they
were like but we didn't even like we're
just walking around we're not even not
even there for this and they're like
don't matter
so you've got that going on my point is
this
what happens when meanwhile we won't
prosecute antifa people oh for sure
Trump trump gets convicted nobody
believes it
Trump gets removed from even a single
state the entire election
will be viewed as illegitimate and
already 2016 was called illegitimate by
democrats 2020 was illegitimated by
Republicans what do you think happens
when they outright just say Trump's off
the ballot Roseanne Barr came on the
show and said there won't be an election
and Michael malice said I'll bet you
money that's not true I said let's
clarify
by election do you mean a typical
election as we know it debate night then
everyone goes and casts their votes on
Election Day then they tell all the
numbers and then we say who won is that
an election
do you mean they Joe Biden will come out
and say I hereby decree there is no
election in bang a gavel or are you
saying Trump will be removed and no one
will think that what is actually
happening is an election like some
facade of election occurs but it's not
legitimately because Trump has already
been removed and so there's no way he
can win and Biden is a foregone
conclusion in which case people say
there was no election yeah and then
you've got half the country or more
slightly more actually because
Independents will probably agree not all
of them
that an election never occurred unless
Donald Trump is allowed to run and
unless he is on all of the states and we
run it like normal
to be fair even then people still won't
believe it but unless that happens
anything that puts a wrench in the
spokes Michigan removes Trump's name
they say oh he's in Georgia removes his
name one state then you're gonna have
half the country say through the states
have the authority to remove his name
from the ballot so under the argument
that they're making for they did it they
did it to a guy they did it to a guy
named Coy Griffin in New Mexico
that he was at January 6 and they said
as an insurrectionist under the 14th
Amendment he is disqualified from
holding office and they remove them
wow that that was their that their their
trial balloon now with Donald Trump they
want to do the same thing but that was
under state law federal okay they use
the 14th Amendment to justify okay so
because the 14th Amendment says anyone
who's raged Insurrection the reason they
keep saying Insurrection is because of
the 14th Amendment yep which basically
says anyone who wages Insurrection
against the US is ineligible blah blah
yep
if Trump is Trump's name is taken off
even one state
you will have a lot you'll have half
this country saying we never had a 2024
election yeah yeah
it's like North Korea at that point they
just say it's North Korea oh yeah the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
had an election and Kim Jong-un got 99.9
of the votes again and then the other
guy who ran against them just goes oh
well you know everyone loves him yeah
and then afterwards they walk back say
here's your paycheck keep your mouth
shut yeah and my problem with this too
is like if you're gonna go ahead and go
after Trump for these charges then you
got to look at the bidens as well man I
mean dudes receiving Millions from China
his son's involved in some of the
nefarious activity
um everyone has their dirt so it's like
okay if you're gonna go ahead and go
after politicians cool go after all of
them yeah they never do then they never
do that's the problem and that's I think
a lot this I feel the same way about the
media like uh as much as we hate the
media and no matter how much you hate
the media you should probably hate them
more in most cases they would feel less
bad if they even made a half of an
attempt to be as willing to go against
people on their own side to to feign
some sense of legitimacy and honesty in
the reporting right if they were willing
to report on Joe Biden's or even Hunter
Biden's incidents half as much as
they're willing to talk about Trump you
could at least feign some sense of
objectivity from the media the same with
the government if they were willing to
go as much against Hunter and Joe not
offer sweetheart deals to Hunter and
actually seem like you were trying to
hold what do they always say speak truth
to power if you were actually trying to
hold power accountable maybe people
might buy it more but they don't because
they understand at least the ones who
are politically aware and Pecos pay
close attention understand that they're
not going to do that because they never
do and this is why mainstream media is
dying you know you guys this is why guys
like you are so important right
alternative media right you guys Joe
Rogan Etc like this is why people are
tuning in to other platforms to go ahead
and get their news I mean CNN MSNBC
these guys are dying the last time they
had as many views is what when Trump was
on the CNN Town Hall like he brought
them a bunch of views they're dying bro
because everyone knows those BS but this
brings up another issue though so
imagine alternate media right we have a
pretty much like free speech so to so to
say however they come after us what's
next because once again Trump is being
you know sorry kind of like put on the
state because
establishment what it was
media personalities are next
100 so yeah well James O'Keefe is under
investigation in New York
and what I was saying was after after
they go for lawyers the next people are
going to be members of the media who are
in communication with Donald Trump and
then who publicly advocated for some
kind of action on January 6th yeah now
James look keeps under investigation
that's more of a general they're
targeting their political opponents but
uh I want to pull up this story
no chance of being fairly considered
doj sues musk SpaceX for Refugee
discrimination
this is the Biden Administration
targeting their political opponents why
because Elon Musk bought X Elon Musk is
allowing people to come back he's
allowing people to speak they can't stop
him they'll try and destroy him I got
this tweet from Elon
somebody tweeted uh Tom Muller said
so if I let a non-us citizen see our
rocket Hardware I go to itar jail but if
I don't hire a non-us citizen I get sued
by the doj got it Elon Musk says SpaceX
was told repeatedly that hiring anyone
who is not a permanent resident of the
United States would violate
International arms trafficking law which
would be a criminal offense we couldn't
even hire Canadian citizens despite
Canada being a part of NORAD this is yet
another case of the weaponization of the
doj for political purposes and he is 100
correct Elon Musk is stepping out in
front of the machine and they are pissed
off about it and so now he is being sued
in the most psychotically imaginable
that he hired too many American citizens
this is crazy because look at Nasa
they're not doing anything right now
compared to SpaceX right so they're
going to hamper SpaceX and take one of
the most you know successful
space-faring companies in recent memory
they're gonna hamper them well you know
there's a handicap I'll tell you what
the real issue is the real issue is that
the doj knows that if Elon Musk actually
builds Starship it's going to crash into
the firmament exploding exposing the
Earth as flat
[Music]
because I know like I keep I have these
friends who are like then why can't you
go to Antarctica Tim and I'm like you
can you can literally go to Antarctica
like there's this weird thing where
they're like if the Earth was round then
why wouldn't why don't they let us go to
Antarctica I'm like some dude filmed
himself marching through Antarctica bro
it's just you got to get a permit for it
they think there's like like government
agents guarding the end of the Earth
well they're right they literally they
flat earthers thing not all of them that
if you get too close to the edge of Flat
Earth there's armed ships that will stop
you they're gonna reassign Trump's
Secret Service after he goes to jail and
send them to the end of the Earth I'll
be completely fair you need a permit to
go to Antarctica yes it's controlled by
various military groups I think there's
like 14 Nations that have territory
there okay and it's just it's yeah
because it's scientific research and
strategic location that's uninhabited if
you can show up on a cargo ship doing
the supply delivery and then like go on
the shore and like look at the Penguins
and stuff like that tons of people do
these little tours you're there for a
few hours and you leave if you want to
do an extended thing you just have to
let the other countries know because it
would be like
entering Russia without a Visa and so
because of that they're like then why
won't they let you go and I'm like bro
you can't go to Russia without a permit
they're not the Earth isn't flat because
Russia is requiring you know visas I
just love the idea though that there's
like a secret conspiratorial Battalion
guarding the edge of the of Flat Earth
so that anyone who gets too close at any
point of the Flat Earth they stop you
like dude there's no secret cabal wow
dedicated to protecting the firmament
that's where all that black budget money
is going gotcha I've never heard the
black the flatter Theory so I this is
all new to me oh this is something I
haven't I haven't we have friends that
believe in it I don't know why but yeah
once again to be fair I've I like
you know I've not gone to outer space
and looked at the Earth so you know but
there's a whole bunch of other reason
why the flight of stuff is just stupid
but it is the Earth is real your other
conspiracy is also wacky as well which
is funny enough yeah well hilarious the
Earth is uh
it's actually uh flat and Hollow I was
gonna say what about Hollow Earth that's
what we really should be talking about
no like this is the real conspiracy
going on Earth see everybody keeps
saying if the Earth is flat and there's
the other one the Earth is hollow I
think it's flat and Hollow it's a donut
okay that's a donut donut Earth theory
which you can't tell waiting for donut
holes in the earth is just a regular
donut would it be crazy though if the
Earth was actually a donut like you are
hanging out in your city on the inner
ring and you look up and you see Chicago
yeah that'd be so weird
Halo you believe in aliens Tim I mean I
believe alien life is possible but
whether or not there's intelligent alien
life roaming around I don't know a lot
of people did until the government said
they were real no I love that
the meme that's like conspiracy
theorists in you know 1990 and it's like
aliens are real yeah right regular
person oh shut up no they're not
conspiracy there 2023 regular person
aliens are real conspiracy there's no
they're not yeah now they're the
opposite yeah anyway back to what we're
talking about though yeah they're going
after Elon
they want to shut down anybody who like
they want to cause Financial harm to
anybody who's helping them out here's a
guy who put Trump back on Twitter
Trump's making a lot of money off that
yeah they're pissed
how are you supposed to stop Trump if
Elon Musk is giving him this massive
platform they try to take away from him
before before Elon had it Trump was
banned off everything I thought he was
allowed back on Facebook or something
recently yeah his band expired or
something it was like two years they're
like okay fine yeah but we can see a
formula that happens with people that
they want to be quiet basically to
cancel your accounts yeah for example
social media bank accounts as well and
then they go out through your family and
then put you in jail the next premium
like death pretty much I like the idea
that like they go after Trump for
listing his weight as incorrect or like
you lied on a government document you
are not 215 pounds that's BS yeah and I
could tell you from experience like when
you book somebody in you don't put them
on a scale you just ask them how much do
you weigh and they'll tell you like okay
Trump's like seven feet tall yeah
they're like you got a boss yeah like
you just like when you and take them
you're like whatever I know you just
write it down it's like okay maybe right
before he got booked yeah maybe eight
like you typically made a question
because like the women always come in
and they lie I'm 100 pounds you're like
it's like a lady I've seen you got four
chins yeah I've seen like three separate
hundred pounds they all look different
yeah yeah like what the hell oh right
right you go on a date how tall are you
six feet come on man I mean yeah
rounding up yeah
but but now they have those high heels
for guys you've seen those right oh yeah
those uh those shoes oh yeah contouring
whatever I don't know what they're
called there's a knee surgery too yeah
surgery
the the leg surgery stuff is messed up
they break your legs apart but they sell
shoes that have inserts so it makes you
two and a half inches taller yeah like
the the second everything is depressive
this is the temple exclusive just so you
guys know
they also ask a question what's fresh
what's your height
and with these shoes I'm six feet oh
these are um
uh Alexander McQueen's but those are
just like normal shoes with a thick Soul
huge platform yeah bottom but they're I
would say those are as close as you can
get without being platforms yeah yeah
yeah like it's a thick Soul it probably
gives you an inch or something yeah
pretty much but they have these they
have those shoes with those things they
or you you buy those Santa
yeah yeah it does you just need to like
learn to accept it like I'm I'm
basically can get like four inches of
height out of that surgery or something
like that yeah I'm like I'm five five
I'm super short I'm like imagine the
embarrassment of like paying all that
money just to be no just to be the
height of the average American male yeah
like just find something else that works
for you yeah
that people are doing this kind of stuff
all this weird it's the male BBL well
again but it's social media influence
man absolutely yeah pretty much so this
is instead of going the route of dating
we'll go to the route of transhumanism
on the conversations right we can talk
about guys wanting to hook up and doing
anything to do it women getting surgery
but there's also people want to be
things they're not guys want to be tall
but they're not tall they want to be
more desirable or some people want to be
a carrot some people want to be a
kangaroo some people they're they're
like there was that tiger man I'm not
Chris identify as a lawnmower yeah
that's right on our show sometimes
honestly bro like I like it I love grass
multiple pieces that's allowed who get
the super realistic dog costumes and
then go walk around the park yeah like
oh there's that one guy doing that in
the car there's two of them there's a
guy it is a wolf and a guy who did it as
a border collie
teacher's gonna be weird dude no it's
it's weird we got one of those VR things
where it's a treadmill we haven't set it
up yet we just got it you strap yourself
in and there's this bowl you stand on
you put on your VR headset and when you
try to run the harness holds you in
place and your feet cause you and VR to
move so you can actually move around 360
degrees and run while in VR on this
treadmill thing people are going to
strap themselves into this the moment
that moment becomes cheap enough for the
average household and they're not going
to go in the real world anymore actually
we had a guy on the show spoke about VR
only fans we're basically you go into
this world and any girl you want to
think of AI generated yes but the only
thing is though you can create your
avatar or create the girl perfect girl
for you and it actually items you can
use to have that same feeling in real
world so you can do your thing with the
only fans girl in a room it's going to
be so creepy metaverse basically you can
pay for it well I'm saying only fans is
going to go out of business yeah because
guys like
it's gonna be a bunch of dudes AI
generating porn for other dudes yeah or
for themselves yeah and they're going to
be able to get that's that's also
everything that they want the future is
going to be gross it's going to be
strange yeah but you know what they if
they let guys if they let the you know
the Transformers into WNBA then you know
we might actually watch the WNBA they'll
be able to dunk and stuff like oh okay
I'll watch them two WNBA uh women
players Brittany Greiner one more
that's a freebie one more one more the
worst trade nobody knows
you may see Plummer what's her name Las
Vegas uh yeah hold on and one more
because Brittany Greiner is the free
space you get it's like name two NBA
star wmb stars outside of Britain oh
cool yeah yeah one more yeah because
everyone knows her for the first time
she went to jail people know that one is
because she's the lady who threw the the
shirts like the top level of the stadium
so they made a big deal about it because
she threw like a basically the
equivalent of like an average NFL
players and we traded her for The
Merchant of death Victor who we spent a
ridiculous amount of money to prosecute
yeah maybe selling weapons I know one
Sarah Harrison see there you go I got
two would you you sure
I did not look that up I made the name
up knowing you guys wouldn't know
the guys go around and he goes he goes I
will give you one dollar or two tickets
to a WNBA game and everybody takes the
dollar yo I mean bro I don't know it's
like a jerk but I mean female sports
like who cares
we both Sports
UFC MMA women's MMA I watch that it's
good it's good I mean I I could give you
that but it's like all other female
sports is like who's there like you know
happy dads and parents yeah go ahead and
here's like I'm I'm off for female
sports because I think it's good that it
keeps uh women away from doing bad
things in their adolescent years right
and if I have a daughter God forbid I'm
gonna put them in sports right but like
professional female sports bro nobody
cares like this crazy purple hair chick
what's her name that wants equal piano
whatever her name is she doesn't want
equal pay she wants a renegotiated
contract because they negotiated their
contract in the first place so
apparently they're like two pay
structures more money up front less
bonus or less money up front more bonus
and they're they negotiated a contract
that chose one over the other which
meant that they got paid less in the
short term than the men and they were
like hey look they're getting paid more
than us
a smart move is good business I have
more power to him here I'm gonna here
you go uh Brittany Grinders are given
she's six foot nine dude that's she's
tall Sue bird oh yeah there you go I
feel like I feel like most famous name
right yeah bird is like the most famous
person I still couldn't remember it but
I know that that's a problem
I'm from uh Connecticut and she played
for UConn's good I've heard of her
before but I wanna Della Don not off the
top of my head though that's that's the
truth you know what's crazy though like
like a good high school men's basketball
team can probably beat a WNBA team oh
yeah oh for sure like that they can
probably be like the like what 15 year
olds beat the women's soccer team yeah
they're like yeah the national team like
it's it dude I just want to be honest
though like the thing about basketball I
don't like there are a lot of really
really good players like Steph Curry
genuine legitimate top tier Talent one
of the best the best legend legendary I
watched a video and it said when you're
so good you can tell when the floor is
broken and he's dribbling and then he
stops and he looks and he points at the
floor and he just knows because he
understands so well I'm like it's
amazing but there I saw that video yeah
right there are players who are just
tall
it's like you are on the team because
you're 7-3 all that matters yeah that's
it Yao Ming was I mean Yao Ming was good
too but you know he's an example right
you're gonna be good to a certain degree
but like if you weren't 7-6 would you be
NBA level no probably not right Mugsy
Bogues was one of the best because he
was what five foot three uh yeah you
some yeah somewhere between five five to
five eight someone could fact check me
on that please I thought it was shorter
than that I thought it was five three
yeah let's see because I remember it
like somebody said like I figured I put
three dude yeah he was like they're
saying he's short I was like yeah short
for the NBA would mean like five eight
right but five three is insane and small
as good as he was this man his story to
me was like
when I when I was younger was told about
a guy who was five foot three but he
could 360 dunk I'm like that shows you
hard work pays off yeah you can be the
best cool dude man absolutely shout to
him yeah inspiration
I don't know what we're talking about
we're talking about now we're talking
about basketball what's that just going
crazy
well no one talked about women's
volleyball so the Chad is roasting the
whole show right now because women's
volleyball is awesome and knowing no one
brought it up fair enough volume two
players uh for volleyball yeah chat name
two players check it out chat listen man
yeah they they don't care
yeah that's why they go into the games
like fantasy volleyball league is Elite
my fantasy volleyball league is Elite my
fantasy volleyball team how much you
think they get paid to play on the
women's volleyball team ah let me look
it up you know the uh less than only
fans girls the Denver the Denver yeah
listen listen
it says the average salary of a
professional female volleyball player in
the U.S is between 35 and 60 000 a year
wow that's low and they train a lot you
could be the a manager at a Giordano's
in Chicago and probably make more than
that damn you could be a UPS driver
remember 170k yeah bottle girl in Miami
walking around in your underwear go and
make it more than that dude the mascots
in the NBA make more than the WNBA
players is that true
Nuggets mascot is like he makes like 600
000 a year the uh the average salary
among 151 wa athletes was 100K in 2022.
okay and the minimum is 62 000 and the
top played payers earn about 234 000.
well here's the thing like they should
be I mean I don't want to sound like a
jerk controversial take doesn't
represent anyone here on the panel
except for maybe myself iron gains but
what I'm gonna say is this they they
can't get mad that they get paid you
know they should be happy they're even
getting six figures because the WNBA is
negative every single year it's
subsidized by the NBA could you imagine
if we have had a men only League that
was negative and they were being paid by
the opposite gender no it would never
exist but you know there's no such thing
as a men's only Sports League yeah I
know I think only in colleges yeah in uh
NBA women are allowed there's no there's
no rule barring women from entering yes
because there doesn't need to be yeah
there have been women who've tried out
to be punters kickers in the NFL yeah
and here's the thing when we could
compete male Sports as well in the at
the professional level and at the
Collegiate level and the thing is is
that and this is because I was division
one athlete and I remember this like
with female sports
um with colleges right if you look at
any big school that has like um a good a
good football team good basketball team
Etc go on their website you're going to
see only a few male Sports then go look
at the women's side they have a bunch of
female sports why because I think it's
called it's Title IX or title 27. that
basically all the money that's allotted
to male Sports has to also be allowed to
female sports at a division one or
division two levels so they end up
having random fencing equestrian all
this crazy stuff and you're like what
the hell so
um yeah I mean female sports are
absolutely funded at the same level
especially at the Collegiate level but
yeah dude like no one cares about female
sports because it sucks no offense well
also I mean the thing is the women don't
support it right men
come out to support men's sports and so
do women because everyone likes watching
people who are at the top of their
fields do something amazing we love to
watch somebody succeed female sports
it's like if the women came out and
supported it it could do fine but they
don't and it's amazing to me how we put
ourselves in compromising situations in
the name of equality I'll explain what I
mean by this so like right we'll have
the WNBA right for equality but it's
negative it doesn't make any money no
one really watches it no one really
supports it like that but we have it
because equality and feelings I mean my
thing too I don't think women should be
in combat positions in the military like
why should we weaken our army by putting
people or our military by putting women
in that don't necessarily have the same
physical capability it's meant because
you're only as strong as your weakest
component so I I'm not saying women
can't join the military but I'm saying
in combat positions Etc this is why for
the longest time women couldn't join
infantry because it compromises the
Integrity of the entire unit because
women just aren't don't have the same
physical capability I'd be pissed if I
went ahead and I signed up and I got a
female in my unit and I get hurt and she
can't drag me to safety well somebody
also explained to me they said that like
a lot of it is like because of the way
men are wired like if a woman gets hurt
in combat it affects their ability to be
uh listen to stay focused yes that that
and then also what if they're taken as a
prisoner of war yeah well that's going
to now be a political
um thing done where they're gonna you
know do certain things to try to show
look at us doing this to America so it's
just the L all around but yeah but when
I'm in a Call of Duty room and I'm with
the boys and a girl joins but I'm like
why are you here what about a losing
right now I'll tell you a story
hostile environment awareness training
they call it heat training which is
redundant because it's
training training it's heat but uh we
did a scenario where
what they do is they bring you in and
they say we're going to give you a
series of scenarios you are journalists
in a foreign country in active conflict
and we're going to do normal jobs and
present you with security risks and uh
so uh they're really it was really fun
uh one of them the first one was like
you're going to a local market to have
coffee and then while you're there one
of the guys one of the people that's
with you because we don't know anybody
so they say hey here are the people that
are on your team which is typical in
like a newsroom like here are the guys
that are going with you while you're
sitting there
they will take one of the people in your
crew and they're gone and then they'll
wait five minutes and come to you and
say all right let's go uh wait where's
John and then I don't know and they'll
be like John's Gone John where are you
how did you guys lose them where'd he go
to simulate someone getting kidnapped
for Market or something like that that's
kind of thing they do we did a scenario
where they said we're gonna go meet with
a journalist we got two cars we're
bringing the full crew they were driving
down the road when a bunch of guys with
guns come out of the bushes stop the
vehicles it's all training it's all
simulations yeah of course and then they
say screaming they fire blanks like
everyone out of the cars
make us lay down
this is part of hostile environment
training if you're if you want to get
this done and then they brought all the
women to a barn and then the women
started screaming and then the guys
doing the training started laughing
saying they were raping the women in the
barn
and then like you you lay on the ground
with guns pointed at you while you hear
the woman screaming yeah what's really
happening is they brought the wind said
okay everyone start screaming yeah and
so the women are just laughing and and
then outside the men are told to listen
to the women being raped oh man and they
were and then when we go back they're
like
this is the kind of thing that will
happen when you are working with female
colleagues and then the funny thing is
because of like labor laws in the United
States somebody somebody said yeah but
like what about men you know it's it's
like there was some weird question of
sexism and he goes what they they could
rape the men too you know maybe they'll
say I'm like oh come on here's the thing
that that feminists don't want to
understand and here's an uncomfortable
truth sexism inherently benefits women
yep like sexism literally creates two
different standards because women can't
compete in most of them and people get
mad at me for saying there's like you're
a massages you're a jerk no I'm just a
guy that understands biological
differences and I think we need to keep
women protected in a way from danger I
don't think women should be in combat
positions in the military I don't think
they should be in law enforcement on the
field I can't tell you how many
situations I've seen where women are in
combat situations on the on the street
with a male perpetrator and they get
overpowered hold on and the guy just
beats the crap out of them and they
can't even get to their weapon on time
and they can't even fight them off but
the real issue is capability yeah I
don't think the issue is women should be
allowed it's people who can't draw their
weapons fast enough people who can't
lift people who are who are not strong
enough because if you got a woman who's
six foot nine yeah pure muscle and
brutish I'd rather have her over a five
foot three you know frail little effect
I'm glad you mentioned that so this is
what I think um and it just so happens
that women can't do this but I'm gonna
say you know what I agree with you it
should be one standard one standard yes
male or female if you can accomplish a
standard fantastic you deserve to be in
but I know right the male standards
right for the military for law
enforcement Etc most women can't do it
at all 50 push-ups 30 push-ups 40
push-ups whatever it may be women can't
do that so my thing is by you watering
down the standards you effectively
weaken the force in the name of equality
it feels before reels unfortunately most
women are not capable of doing these
manual labor jobs that involve combat
and or violence and they shouldn't
either you know we talked about it
earlier on the culture War you're in a
burning building on the third floor or
you're struggling to breathe all sudden
you hear a door bang open and you look
up and there's a five foot tall
100-pound woman carrying this I mean you
be like help me like but if it was
Brittany Greiner comes in at six foot
nine absolutely and picks it with one
hand you're like yeah what did you say
cradle me so it's like that's the point
it's not about male or female yeah like
the joke I make is like dude if I'm in a
burning building and then the door
bursts open and it's a six foot five
chiseled manly man glistening with sweat
and he smiles us I'm here to save it
babe cradle me like save me dude I don't
care yeah there's no princess I'm gonna
burn to death yeah and if it's Brittany
grinder I said the same thing like if
you can save me save me yeah it's just
that the idea that that they they've
lowered the standards for fire
departments and for police and for
things like this we shouldn't lower the
standards at all yeah they should be the
same anybody can come like like
feminists like to cry like sexism and
all this other stuff sexism benefits
women because it creates a second
standard for them to be able to compete
if we weren't being sexist we would have
one standard and we would be like okay
ladies go ahead and compete with the men
but they never be able to get in they'd
be like if you want to play basketball
join the NBA and it's like there's no
woman tall enough fast enough I mean I I
do think it's curious I wonder how
Brittany Greiner would do she's six foot
nine How would how would she do on
average in the NBA well she wouldn't
even make it like there's High School
boys that would absolutely like smoker
there you go like like yeah it's it's
like it's it's incredible like people
don't realize like how good you have to
be in the to be in the NBA a guy at the
end of the bench that barely made the
team is smoking 99 of people in the
world like you are literally the best of
the best like a division one basketball
player can go ahead and show up and
smoke anybody like especially with
basketball at an international level
like these guys are really good
so Brittany grinder needs to go join the
fire department then is what you're
saying I'm not saying that she probably
can't pass a physical test and drag a
200 pound person I think it's 150 pound
bag is that what it is I could be wrong
but my understanding is they have you
carry you go up uh to a second floor
then you throw a 150 pound bag over your
shoulder and have to run down oh yeah
most women can't do it but that's gone I
don't I mean that's that's heavier than
the average woman I think the average
woman is like 120 or something 170. yeah
187 pounds bro like these women are huge
and and there are more fat women than
fat dudes by the way shout out to all my
black queens
170.8 pounds dude ridiculous five foot
four yeah
these chicks are whales man it's getting
crazy out here man the harpoons and the
harpoons
dude like it's crazy because it's like
as a female like dude you have one job
just like be attractive
guy America please the average American
man 20 years old weighs 197.9 pounds
with a 40 inch waist circumference at
five foot nine yeah wow yo so today I
just want to imagine I'm sorry go ahead
and imagine this dude is jacked he's got
so much muscle that he's got 40 inches
of pure muscle at five foot nah that
that is just fat yeah we're just fat
it's all in America yeah and I will say
this I I realize how fat we are when I
leave Miami because Miami is pretty fit
City once I leave I'm like wow we really
are fat and there's even more fat women
so today I went for a walk to the whis
uh Supermarket whatever I think that's
like a supermarket twice and
um I was learning to see how many people
were fat literally
crazy because I'm because Miami is kind
of like pseudo our food South America
and stuff but like you leave like South
Florida you leave so like somewhere else
you're like oh wow there's a lot of fun
I think our food's poisonous oh yeah
yeah well yeah because what I hear from
everybody is oh when I was in insert
country I was eating the same amount of
food and I lost weight when I came to
America I just gained weight crazy on
camera seven years ago I was skinny as a
stick dude I started the American food I
got fat I'm like what's going on with me
I go back to Barbados skinny it's like
when you exactly here it's like I know
it's hormones or what but it's really
bad in it yeah everyone didn't tell me
that that comes here foreign or used to
live here and then they leave and then
they lose weight yeah I agree with you
because when I go to other places I lose
weight and I'm here we were in Columbia
we ate hella food I was I felt good I
didn't feel bloody at all but were you
eating like rice and chicken or were you
eating cheeseburgers Burgers no fries
and chickens no yeah I eat healthy all
the time I wouldn't be I wouldn't be
surprised like if you were to go down to
Central America and have Burgers and
Fries and lose weight because it's the
oil we use too yeah so right now a big
thing everyone's freaking out about seed
oils I don't know about all that I do
know that I someone posted this article
wear canola oil which we use for cooking
used to be used for like engine
lubricant what yeah there's a bunch of
food that we have here in the United
States that's like banned in Europe and
other places and another thing too is
like our portion sizing is ridiculous
and to be a thousand we uh absolutely
encourage people to be fan United States
we don't but we need to go back to body
fat body fat shaming I think we need to
make fun of fat people we need to bring
it back we need to make fun of fat
people well to be fair if lizard can do
it why can't we do it yeah dude if I was
prime minister well if I was President
United States I'd have fat people in
shape in 30 days the the 99 tax gag is
to tell people to compliment women that
they look like lizzo
yeah yeah pretty much yeah and they all
kind of scrambled I don't know I'm angry
they'll be like hey
even though they sit there and say fat
is beautiful I think genuinely so here's
the thing that I've noticed about
females when they accompany each other
they don't really mean anything they say
to each other it's also sabotage oh no
it's okay you you be a oh no it's
okay be fat no exercise your sexual
Liberation they do that right because yo
I don't have to compete with this chick
no more yeah loser be a loser women give
each other self-destructive device all
the time every single time girls in a
happy relationship with a guy oh you
should leave him what are you doing why
are you cooking why are you cleaning
from are you a slave come on girl what's
wrong with you and it literally
perpetuates why so many women stay
single there's nothing worse than having
a girlfriend and she hangs out with her
single friends they're going to poison
her there's this uh like Trope that I've
heard from people in the military
there's like a story where
when women start basic training they're
all friends they all get along
and then by the end of it they all hate
each other yeah when men start basic
training they're all arguing and
fighting and by the end they're all
working together yeah that like the
social dynamics are inverted yeah men
Bond over like um a shared goal well so
so versus women aren't like that so my
understanding was
what men are actually doing is figuring
out who's the most capable to lead and
so the head butting and chest bumping is
like roosters being like I'm in charge
no I'm in charge and then after the
trials and tribulations the men figure
out who actually is the best and then
align themselves based on that perceived
hierarchy right whereas women are in
constant competition with each other for
the best men yeah so by the end of it
they're all like I gotta sabotage I
gotta sabotage well this is why this is
why people get mad at me for saying this
but this is why you need male leadership
like women aren't capable of leading
anything in a relationship except the
end of it so it's like God you need that
male leadership and that male
instruction you know a woman without
instructions headed for Destruction
but if you look at it you look at the
things that like women are attracted to
in men they're all inherently
um centered around leadership dominance
strength perseverance capability
competence Etc it's all survival traits
that women look for in men men don't
look for any of these things in women we
don't care about how much money a woman
makes her success or her um um income or
any of that stuff because women look for
that men look for replication value
women look for survival value want young
and hot they want capable strong Etc
look at the bad boy he's he kind of like
shows leadership he shows strong he
throws a guy that can actually fight and
even though he's not the best option
pretty much the bad boy shows those
traits so you're right and here's the
other thing too with men like men
naturally fall in a hierarchy of
dominance and success and competence
because there's always that threat of
violence right because men are willing
to fight right to
um to express themselves to a degree
right and then and they just kind of
fall in line with women it doesn't
really operate that way they did I'll
never forget the Survivor right they put
the men and the women and put them
against right two different islands dude
the women were like arguing about if
they were going to hunt and kill the
animal they couldn't make fire they
couldn't make shelter Etc it ended up
happening so check this out very
interesting I forget what season it was
but someone in the chat's probably gonna
put it so the guys they're in the
building fire they're in the building a
home and everything right they build
everything up and they're good right
they're hunting and they got they got
their stuff going right so the women
figure out okay we don't know we're
doing we're living like we're we're
terrible right so the chicks go over to
the lower status males in that group and
tell them Hey listen can we get some of
your resources blah blah blah and they
finessed them and the guys right the
symptoms that they are go ahead and give
some of the resources right and that
causes turmoil with the other guys so
the women knew if we go to the weaker
guys right the beta males I hate to use
those terms but we go to those guys we
could manipulate them and get some of
their resources that caused a bunch of
information about the guys this is what
happens when female influence comes in
there's a better men aren't strong there
was another show where they put men and
women on two different islands
and the women
were crying lost
super upset they uh and and the
feminists argue that the show is staged
to insult women because it's hilarious
and everyone it goes viral but there was
like one where the women are like we
need to find water so we're gonna go
search for water we'll be back and they
started walking in circles and then once
they walked past the same icon this
woman broke down started crying being
like how does this happen like how are
we lost it's like someone who's never
walked in the forest doesn't realize how
easy it is to get lost because you don't
realize when you turn if like you're
walking through the trees the trees
aren't a straight path yeah so like
I recently walked around an island and
the path you're walking on feels
straight yeah and then you you walk like
two miles and you're like we just walked
in a big circle it's crazy yeah you it's
it's slightly curved but it's so big you
don't know you're going in a big circle
and men have far more so they know that
like this is scientifically proven men
have more spatial awareness than women
men that's why men are better with
directions and being able to manipulate
the world you know and why that's why
we're better at building things and it's
not to say the mood or Buddha women but
we're just better at certain things that
tend to deal with infrastructure so it's
like it's very interesting how and I've
said this before guys get so mad not
guys but like people get mad at me for
saying this but men need to understand
that women are hardwired to extract
resources for men like that's what
they're hardwired to do when it comes to
true you know raw survival Etc that's
what women do they use their beauty to
extract resources for men and it's on
you to make sure you don't get finished
we're gonna go to Super Chat so smash
that like button subscribe share the
show with your friends become a member
at timcast.com to support our work
directly and pick up your tickets to the
Miami event on sale now Patrick Bet
David Donald Trump Jr and maggates
lugerkowski me we're going to be doing
the show on stage live and we're also
going to have like audience q a and
stuff it's gonna be a lot of fun all
right rain gutter Corey says Trump
pulled off blue steel better than
Zoolander himself that was blue steel
wasn't it and they spelled it s-t-e-a-l
like steal the election no no just
regular steel but it would have been
funny no people posted that at the
bottom oh really blue Steve amazing
has just released our latest track
Higher Ground are you still offering
grants for those contributing to culture
creation if so we would greatly
appreciate you giving us a listen we'll
definitely check you out let me write it
down
that's nice
bullet pin it's cool it looks like a 50
BMG yeah so take a look at this pen it
looks like a bullet but
Ben wow oh
we got a couple of them actually they're
really cool I'm stealing one
Anthony Sanford says in solemnity of
Trump's mug shot we should all change
our profile pictures to that beautiful
orange scowl it's happening right now it
is happening a lot of people are doing
it yup yup shoe one head as uh Trump's
mug shot shot the Trump man I like it
she won had posts these people always
accusing her of being a guy
she all right she's done it more than
once
she went that's great yeah funny
what do we got
vocalos Al Corlin says you know I have
to wonder how much of the money the
government's sending to Ukraine is
getting funneled back into the pockets
of certain politicians oh large portions
of them facts yeah zelenski's a criminal
he knows that he took a bunch of money
to build roads AKA never built the roads
yeah that's one of the few things he's
done or not done in this case
Brian
in INF Edge says look at all the hate
Watchers in chat y'all just clowns that
can't stack paper to the ceiling and
ride on 20-inch chrome wfnf
shout out to you man thank you for the
special team man
we got a lot of haters but it's okay
KB says Trump was right he never came
back to Twitter LOL that's right he's on
X now different thing
Amos Moses says when are you having
Congressional candidate Brandon Herrera
AKA AK jesusan uh in like a week or
something I don't know I don't know I
don't know where he's going it's coming
up I don't remember if it's next week
but it'll be soon yeah so yeah he's
coming cool
coming coming Jason Dixon says one of
our Discord members owns a business
called gcwindsor.com
his his product is excellent for the
fresh and fit audience his product is
designed to Bringing men to the next
level in their fashion game love your
work very cool thank you for the support
bro that's important man MB says make
the poker show legal by winners playing
for Charities that change the culture
finally got our 501c3 approved to
support home schools Massachusetts would
love you to play for us that was one of
the considerations but no consistent
weekly player wants to play for charity
so we want to do a poker show okay and
it's mostly table talk like you know
when we were all hanging out
talking smack and joking and laughing
that's more what the show is and poker
is just what we're doing at the table
gotcha so you probably just dudes being
crude yeah but attitude for teaching me
how to play poker yeah well mostly a lot
yeah he was super excited he loves poker
but just just don't fall bro don't fold
don't fold sometimes you gotta fold you
gotta known to hold them no one to fold
them oh just kidding
but we want to do the show and the
challenge is we need a consistent lineup
of players
guests the players the core like six
maybe like five of the players are going
to be locals who want to play a cash
game if we were like it's all for
charity then the players are going to be
like count me out like I'm not playing
to just make some donation because these
are not celebrities and we can't get
eight celebrities every week the idea is
just to have a handful of locals and
like one or two guests and then we're
sitting on table and we're all just
smack talking and making jokes and it's
just open this is for kids for
homeschool no this is no no but like
with the the Charities okay but the
Charities to fund so kids didn't have
homeschooled no she's saying we should
do various Charities okay also she has a
charity that we could use okay but
nobody wants to play for charity gotcha
it's a thing they do with celebrities
where they'll play poker for Charities
and then the winning players money goes
to the charity but no small like no
local cash player wants to do that no
you play online or not really nah it's
not the same huh it's I I yeah okay
gotcha I like there are people who are
super hardcore like poker culture into
poker and they love online and they love
live and I'm just like the only game I
care about is playing with real people
gotcha because I don't care about
looking at a digital screen and seeing
buttons click and Graphics slide around
that's just boring to me okay but in
real life you watching people sweat one
guy's talking smack about the other guy
yeah people are shaking it's a lot more
fun but mostly when you're hanging out
the table people are just talking about
everything yeah it's like you go to
these tables and it's really funny uh my
friend Robbie was out here we're in West
Virginia we're playing at Charlestown
and this guy Robbie got a mouth on him
and so he just looks at one guy goes are
you a libtard
and then he goes excuse that's what I
call them too and he's like bro are you
libtard and he's like I'm a liberal and
he goes oh he's like I don't mean
anything by it and then everyone busts
out laughing like bro what are you doing
like this but the guy like I guess they
got they got along I don't know because
he's just goofing off but like that's
funny at the table when people are
acting silly yeah yeah
yeah and it's like and and it is 90 men
sometimes there's women there
it's almost always men yeah isn't that
kind of crazy like what do women do you
know what I mean I don't mean that
literally drinks what I mean is like
guys from our perspective is we're
always engaging kind of activity you
know what I mean like the majority of
the people watch this show 80 guys yeah
skateboard let's go to skate park almost
all guys yeah go to the poker room
almost all guys go to uh baseball game
like excuse me if we're gonna be honest
dude like I mean men absolutely dominate
all human men are the best at most human
Endeavors and women are mediocre in most
human Endeavors and the reality is is
that most of them don't have hobbies
being honest there's some exceptional
women that like are great at certain
things but most girls would rather just
hang out and go to the mall and watch
Drama TV I mean we ask them on the show
what are your hobbies and they don't
have Beach
like like most girls like honestly like
if you actually like this one we've done
this before yeah yeah blindfold and like
listen to the and like you go on like a
blind date literally you're blind and
she's talking to you and you're just
like what the hell what are are you
stupid like what's going on here like
once you take off like their looks like
they really a lot of girls are just
boring and don't do anything
but those are those are Hobbies I mean
we as guys around the table we don't
want to go to the mall we don't want to
just sit and talk all day women enjoy
this is a hobby though it's it's a hobby
we're not going to find it fulfilling
we're not going to find it cool wait
hold on hold on if you if you met a
check and you said what do you want your
hobbies and she goes I like to go out
into wildlands and
like uh forage for fruits and learn
about the plants and look for seeds and
plant things would you call that a hobby
yeah that'd be interesting that is I'm
not a scientist I'm saying my
understanding is that's the root of
shopping
so like human tribal Behavior was men
would go hunt so men are going out and
seeking these this kind of conflict and
women would forage so the women would go
together and walk around looking at
trees and being like Oh you know they
grab the berries and they'd grab fruits
and vegetables and they would gather
while the men yeah but they're actually
working when they're shopping they're
spending their money what I'm saying is
shopping is a facsimile of foraging but
you go there and you look around at all
the things you want but Tim let's Brew
here
the last time that happened Adam and Eve
we saw what happened to the world you
know what eating foraging yeah she took
the fruit well she got tricked though
she fell for it and she took Adam
Marion Holtzman says crooked lawyers
judges and prosecutors will absolutely
do or say anything to get president
Trump if nothing comes of it at least
they can say we tried this is all a big
fat diversion trying to get eyes off the
Biden crime family yeah it's gonna hurt
his reputation regardless I agree and
they don't they don't look at Biden yep
these uh GC Windsor guys are really
really excited and want us to let you
guys know they exist Jeffrey shout out
to them yeah he said I'm Jace GC Windsor
Jeff the Discord member with the
extremely unique product that everyone
has been noticing I believe I have a
story that she would love to hear
through through an interview if you
would consider it sounds with them said
freshman CEO DM no I'm looking for it
okay what's it GC Windsor GC Windsor
yeah okay no idea I don't know what it
is just put Tim Cass in all caps and
I'll find it what do we got it better be
good brother better be good oh and for
all the people that are wondering guys I
did a hair transplant this is my real
hair it's not a toupee yeah last time he
was here yeah I was bald as hell but I
did it I did a hair transplant and I
didn't even notice yeah I cut like a
yeah I was balled as hell last time I
was here uh I basically cut like a strip
of my head and then they like take out
the hair follicles from that strip of uh
your skin and then they pluck it in the
parts where you have thin hair and now
but I love her but it's like they take a
little piece but now you have a full
head of hair yeah so like they cut a a
cut in the back your head I got like a
scar back here right oh wow and then
they take that piece of skin and there's
a whole bunch of hair follicles they
take each pluck each follicle of hair
and pluck it into the parts that were
thin so it's basically like a hair BBL
kind of yeah but it's my real hair guys
I do not have hair under the beanie can
I see it completely yeah after the show
so right now we're battling between
waves right and are here you know I've
only been brush it for two weeks but
right now I'm winning the battle because
I'm black we're not bro I'm darker okay
so I'm winning yeah so why do it why get
the hair plugs no no I don't consider
wearing a beanie no there's no Hair Plus
yeah uh I would just like dude like I'm
on camera I'm getting bald because I
like dealing with girls every night and
debating them got annoying like dude
it's more stressful dealing with these
chicks than chasing after terrorists
[Laughter]
like what the hell is going on here so
like yeah I lost hair from like debating
these ridiculous girls you don't got me
wrote when I say like a fight man I'm
like what if you want to fight a man
that makes no sense to me and say how
many girls that come on the show I could
fight him and I'm like why it's all the
movies in the television but it sounds
like you and you're surrounding yourself
with no dude
regular college degree listen they're
from Europe I get it from Canada they're
from America there's no saving I'll say
this this is what I've realized about
women that are educated they tend to be
even more grounded in their delusion let
me explain don't make 100 000 per year
Well I make hundred thousand dollars per
year I deserve a man that makes a
hundred thousand dollars per year no you
look like a garden gnome you don't
deserve a guy that makes that kind of
money but they think because they make
that kind of money and they have a
certain status or whatever that they
deserve that guy but they don't realize
that men don't care about they don't
realize that they don't have it it's not
about this yeah like men don't care
about that's it right there
there was an article from New York post
that I read a few years ago that
triggered a bunch of feminists they all
started screaming at me and it's it was
uh career women struggled to find men
who make as much money as they do yes
yes and it was like this woman she's 32
and she makes 50 000 a year and she
can't find a man who makes that much
money and I was like I'll I'll break it
down for you and I don't mean to be rude
but if there's a 32 year old guy making
50 000 a year he's going to be dating a
23 year old yeah because fifty thousand
dollars to a 23 year old is a lot of
money yeah
that and it's not a lot of money to you
so like if a guy is in his 30s and has
money and has access to a younger dating
poison Trek to why would he go for him
in his own age
I'm not saying it's right you speak it
too much logic to him I'm not saying
it's right I'm just saying that your
massage and I was like you know you know
my advice to these women is they got to
date a guy who's 45. yeah and then
they're gonna find a guy who's but but I
guess their argument was they they want
a guy who makes as much as they do yeah
but I don't think guys want that no they
don't know also it's been yeah and women
are now like a lot of metrics are saying
like because women are graduating
college at higher levels right they're
earning more and they're out and they're
out earning them which is just actually
making them more miserable shrinking
their own dating people while trying to
tell them that they're happy yeah
feminism it's facts is the greatest gift
to ultra high tier men yeah three men
yeah women are told to be promiscuous to
abort their babies yup so the men can do
whatever they want they have to do very
little work now they'll enter getting
the jobs they're getting the phds and
they're working they're working these
office jobs and the ultra high value man
can sit back play video games all day
and then tell them when we have 12 12
wives or whatever it's it's ridiculous
yeah dude what feminism has done is it's
inadvertently given all the leverage to
the top one percent of men in the sexual
Marketplace who are never going to
commit to them anyway yeah yeah all
right we'll grab some more we'll grab
some more yeah let's do it
what do we got I love listening to gso
five nine says they never forgot that he
said to peacefully to protest peacefully
they just got done peacefully protesting
for over a year and no uh and know what
it means that's right
yep so when they said
um mostly peaceful protest and then they
heard Donald Trump say protest
peacefully they were like we know what
he means
wow
all right
Marion Holtzman says geez none of you
are legal experts this conversation of
what ifs is totally fruitless
uh thank you for the hundred dollar
Super Chat to let us know but but I'll
read your criticism I mean I think there
was a very valid discussion we talked
about the statutes we talked about what
potentially could happen people can hate
bro
[Music]
notify by TV and newspaper if you don't
have a mailing address or residence I
had to sue my wife with no contact info
yes but that's a special circumstance if
they know where he lives and everyone
does legal service needs to be delivered
but to your point yes that would be
serving a warrant and saying yeah for
criminal investigations a bit different
but yeah and I think Trump should have
been like yeah absolutely that's what
you should do yeah
something something says Hillary was not
allowed to be served because the Secret
Service didn't allow it her lawyer said
that they couldn't take uh take it take
it had to be served to her directly
Tulsi gabbard was unable to sue Hillary
for defamation wow
oh really I didn't know that that's
crazy
damn
he went from crooked Hillary to Crooked
Biden he talked about that in the Tucker
interview too that was funny Keane
speaks says what if it was safer to
respond in the manner he did where Trump
is able to fly in his own accord to the
station which allows him to make a media
spectacle of the legal spectacle just my
thoughts I I think Trump's team planned
it I don't think it was just legal I
think it was I think it a PR guy it was
fundraising right and he doesn't get the
merch drop if he doesn't get to do it
that way I bet he's going to make 50
million bucks for some ridiculously
obscene number yeah he he spent in his
favor man they keep losing these guys
the more they indict him the more they
talk about them in the media negatively
the more people support him
yeah Ginger MC Isaac says now that Trump
now has a mug shot he would be more
relatable to someone disadvantaged yep
don't those people tend to vote blue
sounds like a possible Dilemma to me you
know what's funny by them taking that
mug shot which is you know Atlanta's you
know mostly African-American they've
basically like they've galvanized
African Community because they're like
yeah oh yo especially the hip-hop
committee like I saw a couple people on
Instagram right now
went to jail
one of the most legendary rappers I know
today Chief Keef posted Trump his mug
shot homie
that's crazy bro like let's just get a
backfire they were like we're gonna
arrest Trump and then Trump's got uh
Trump's uh political advisor is like you
are going to Skyrocket with black males
yeah in the voting like if you do this
and he was like let's go yeah so it's
it's literally like backfiring on them
you know hold on we're laughing about it
but I think you guys are right yeah
because in his on his website he talks
about how the jail is bad how it's how
it's the clinicians are awful and how
it's horrible how they treat people
I wonder if they were like hey let's
turn this into uh Target people who feel
disenfranchised or have been to jail use
this to your advantage yeah wow and that
used to be a demographic that would
never vote for him because he was so Pro
law enforcement Etc so now like it's
funny because Democrats like always try
to appeal to the African-American
Community like we're going to give you
guys we're going to help you guys out
more blah blah blah but they never do so
this is actually them shooting
themselves in the foot because now
they've effectively made their
opposition
have an image of sympathizing with the
very Market that they try to Market to
the most to get their votes they made a
white man relatable to the black man
there you go literally he can also point
to the first step act in the work they
did there with yeah within the community
as far as people who'd been jailed for
but that's like a hard policy question
you have to know about yeah Trump
getting arrested then being like that's
how that jail was whacked they're gonna
be like yeah you've got rappers that
never supported him supporting him now
he's crazy to me bro that have a huge
platform you want to know what's messed
up
out of the 19 defendants only one was
remanded without bond
only one who
only won
who
what do you think his race was
black black
the only oh only Trump defense no I'm
sorry that's that yeah yeah the only one
my understanding the only one was
remanded right am I right yeah so the
one that was
a director for black voices for Trump uh
I can't remember his name only one
romantic to be fair though there was I
think there there might maybe one or two
other black defendants who were not
remanded but I do think it's funny that
the only one who does oh my God I'm like
they're racist so they're all kinds like
those scary movies where the black
person dies first right oh yeah pretty
much that's well man let's grab some
more Jesus says got my cast brew coffee
and Ripper first comic today thank you
Tim and Eric best day in a while awesome
yes Tim and Eric how how very great
no no you get it Tim and Eric you don't
know Tim and Eric is you're not familiar
with Tim and Eric oh wow you guys don't
know what Tim and Eric is no is that you
somebody else no well yes they're
referring to me and uh air July but Tim
and Eric was a show on Adult Swim oh ah
okay no I don't remember oh wow I mean
there you go cultural relevance Sean
Lewis the really good uh really good
really good post says Trump quote I will
surrender paying the full 200 000 if
Georgia donates all of the money to help
the Hawaii fire victims otherwise serve
the warrant and come get me um
after the conversation we just had I
understand why he surrendered now
because the guy the rich Elite getting
pulled out of his house by cops it's not
going to look good especially for lower
class kind of people so that's why he
surrendered image yeah and and also like
I said the Optics like they already have
him as an insurrectionist so it's like
by him saying I'm not coming blah blah
they can go ahead and say see you it's
all job to worry sex the sky it doesn't
lie he's trying to overthrow the
government he doesn't even follow the
law a peaceful surrender they would say
okay I get it yeah it's it's an optic
situation man because it's crazy how
they've spun January 6 to make him look
like it was he was he's an
insurrectionist when he he literally
said protest peacefully but they always
tend to forget that I think if uh I was
gonna put this in words I was gonna be
more relatable
Trump is now my wigger
this ain't bro there you go
Chad conego says the Earth is a donut
the Moon is the donut hole that proves
it dude
that proves it yep interesting Raymond
Magnuson says correct me if I'm wrong if
Trump is acquitted in the false
alternate electors charge could this
give the Democrats precedence to use
alternate electors themselves at the
discretion of Kamala Harris
it's really interesting alternate
electors are not illegal they've been
done before in 1961 Richard Nixon as
vice president rejected the certified
Republican uh uh electors in favor of
the uncertified Democrat electors by
personal choice because the vice
president can do that that's the
precedent by which Donald Trump was like
I'll do the same thing and they said
nope you can't illegal which is just not
true it may be illegal now to change the
law but the vice president always had
the authority to reject votes that's the
purpose of the vice president to say
it's ceremonial no it's it's literally
not it's the vice president Thomas
Jefferson did a two of them not mistaken
rejected electors I think so I don't
know about that I know in 1876 I think
it was alluded to in his uh interview
with Tucker 1876 the end of
reconstruction they didn't know which
electors to count there was a Civil War
was on the verge of breaking out again
and they said okay let's compromise and
just figure out who's gonna be president
and so the the agreement was okay you
can be president but reconstruction is
over this is the case of they can do it
but I can't do it yup pretty much that's
exactly it sad reminds me of us
oh yeah bro we can relate my wiggle man
oh wait we should definitely relate yeah
Trump we do certain things a weekend to
be lies for it bad but other people do
it cellular says men's gymnastics is
subsidized by USA Gymnastics which is
primarily funded by the women although
it's bad because Title IX decimated
men's NCAA which negatively affected our
Olympic performance there we go Title IX
that's what it is yeah that that is one
thing I think gymnastics
I'm not super familiar with it but it
sounds like that one's where it's just
mostly heavily heavily female
I can tell you that when I was a kid all
of the gymnastics programs in my area of
Chicago didn't allow boys it was only
only for girls
yeah they get more funding too but why
why is gymnastics only for girls I mean
like well they could do backflips yeah
no it's for men too but it's just not as
highlighted because it's not as funded
like for I can give an example like
men's rowing right I wrote division one
at Northeastern University like we even
though we were a better team right and
we ranked higher than the women's team
because the women team absolutely sucked
um they they got way more funding
because of Title IX because it was oh I
see yeah so that's what ends up
happening a lot of times
David Toronto says women's tennis is
legit at least in the money making
department but the best pro woman
couldn't beat a D1 man not even close
yeah I mean Serena Williams would lose I
mean I think she lost an exhibition game
to like I hung over dude yeah they said
they could beat any man ranked 200 and
he was like okay I'll do it and then he
showed up smoking and drinking and won
[Applause]
I mean I write that on the internet I
don't know it's true no it's true she
got smoked bad it's it's uh yeah dude
I mean I say this on a podcast all the
time when girls get mad at me I say you
know women are physically inferior to
men
yeah that's so messed up and it's like
no it's the truth like like and even in
other endeavors right you look at video
games you look at chess you look at
Formula One driving you look at things
that aren't even necessarily physical
but maybe just a reactionary time men
dominate that too
we love women by the way yeah yeah we
just acknowledge the differences between
us and I think women need to be put in
positions where they have more
advantages like the kitchen all right
costly gold says canola uh what Canola
was originally a trademark name of the
rape seed Association of Canada
the name was uh was a condensation of
can from Canada and Ola meaning oil low
acid really I thought I thought that was
it's like it comes from us but oh is it
is that what it is rape seed is that is
that what it is I know that I had no
idea what it was all I know is I always
just see the things that's canola oil
and it's got like a weird plant and I'm
like I don't know it's food but I don't
use it I like using uh I like using
butter for basically everything though
yeah just if I'm going to use oil it's
gonna be butter and then I'm gonna drink
a glass of heavy cream take a stick of
butter and just microwave it a little
bit and then pour it right into my mouth
I was gonna say yeah that's a lot of
calories bro I do have like a fourth cup
of heavy cream for breakfast and that's
it okay is peanut oil better than
regular oil because that's what what's
regular oil though I don't know just
whatever they use other than peanut oil
yes absolutely because Chick-fil-A I
can't I can't I can't tell you where's a
woman we need to ask this question yeah
I'll just say this I would I would
rather have I would rather have peanut
oil than canola oil but I'd rather have
avocado oil or olive oil than peanut oil
and I'd rather have butter than any of
it yeah olive oils I think butter is
just the best or organic grass-fed and
finished butter yeah I learned this I
didn't know this grass-fed beef what do
you think that means
cows that eat grass that's not what it
means I was it means that at some point
they gave the cow grass oh wow at some
point grass finished means the cow only
ate grass oh yup so you get these these
like weasels in the store and it says
grass-fed beef and they're like right
when they were young we've had them
grass and then we switched them over to
grains oh my God grass finished means
they ate nothing but they foraged their
whole lives like when they put like
candy and they say 100 fruit and they're
like wait no it is okay no no they say
100 pure beef and then they argue
legally yes of the ten percent of the
burger that's beef it is 100
conspiracy here
organic food is it real how do you tell
this organic or not how do you know they
still spray pests they get certified and
a lot yeah it does it's there's like
certain regulations as to what they can
or can't use in terms of pesticides and
other chemicals that are on organic food
but uh we have coffee at casper.com it
is all certified organic it that means
it's a certain process by which they
don't use certain chemicals and things
like that and then we have to prove it
submit it to the government who then
says we agree with the assessment and
they slap the label on it saying we
checked yeah shout out to all the vegans
shout out ladies and gentlemen if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends yes become a
member at timcast.com you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast do you guys want
to shout anything out uh yeah we're not
doing any more chats you've done that's
it we're rapping oh shout out time uh
guys check us out on uh fresh and fit
man on YouTube and Rumble um and yeah I
mean pretty much it yeah pretty much we
live stream uh Mondays Wednesdays and
Fridays we do the daytime show Money
Mondays womanizer Wednesdays and then
call and show and or guest Fridays and
then we do the after hour show with the
girls where we debate different topics
and um yeah man and then check me out on
fed reacts if you guys like the criminal
justice stuff that I talk about give you
guys Insight I cover serial killers
terrorism cases murder famous case high
profile cases I break down cases like
this with the Trump situation I read the
legal documents give you guys my
professional assessment on it and yeah
man we give you all everything thank you
for having us bro and thank you for
having us Tim well yeah cultural that
was really really fun yeah and I'm glad
you guys we'll see you in Miami and
we're going to have Tim on the Pod I
know people some of you guys were
probably wondering hey hold on you guys
schedule the show whatever we just had
like some technical difficulties because
Tim has a different setup than we do um
but Tim's gonna come to Miami and we're
going to have him on the Pod so don't
worry we'll definitely talk to Tim when
do you guys do your normal show uh 6 p.m
6 P.M Monday Wednesday Friday yeah
one-on-one and then girls like nine yeah
so yeah um but yeah guys fresher fit on
YouTube and Rumble check us out over
there Tim do me a favor though shout out
to rumble man come in October to Miami
interview with no beanie that's not
gonna happen
man thanks for having us on the show
it's always great this is our third time
on yeah and it's always really fun
coming up here and hanging out so even
though we're out in the middle of
nowhere I'll tell you guys a funny story
first time we ever came out here right
it's out in the middle of nowhere and
man first get out the car and it's all
dark and I'm like bro that's it dude
we're done this this is a setup we're
there's no podcast it's a rap for us and
uh it was a great time I should have
stayed in Barbados man yeah like burning
crosses or something yeah
podcast but Tim's always a great host
man it's always fun to be here it's
always uh great to hang out with you
guys and chat it up yeah right on man
all right guys if you want to follow me
you can follow me on Instagram and X
slash Twitter at Brett dasovic on both
of those platforms pop culture crisis is
Monday through Friday 3 P.M Eastern
Standard time we talk pop culture
celebrities movies entertainment all
that stuff coming out with us
and you guys can follow me on X at
Kellen PDL where I uh re-x my friends
and co-workers when they post some great
points uh but yeah follow me there
thanks guys it was fun hanging out with
you all tonight check out the clips
we'll have up throughout the weekend and
then we are back Monday thanks for
hanging out
peace